e
e e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
several hearings planned today but
before we get to them I'd ask you to
please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance
the pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank you
everyone I'd like to welcome
Representative Steve kessle Wing to the
committee um sitting over there U so
welcome representative kessle
uh the first bill to be considered this
morning is uh hb70
dfn uh Prime sponsor is representative
David Nagel from bellnap County and
representative Nagel if You' like to
come forward uh and introduce the
bill um thank you sir it's a pleasure to
be here
um as you know or you just said I
represent I was very proud to create a
bipartisan coalition to truly represent
the needs of gilmington Guilford and W 2
of
Laconia and it's my honor to present
this bill to you which is not simple
it's common sense to me but I know to
other people it may not be so um I would
bear ask you to bear with me as we go
through this
um just as a preface that I feel
obligated to say at this time I am the
luckiest person in the world and I know
I'm quoting somebody else and saying
that and no I do not have a bad
neurological disease right now um but I
really am um for most of my life I've
been able to advocate for the rights of
those who are stigmatized by those
around them too off and those who had
promised to help them um for the past 40
years I've been able to do that for a
living and that is such a
blessing as rewarding as that can be at
times it's really challenging in such
times um I draw strength from this book
um I read this first when I was 12 years
old um it's the Gail sers autobiography
was a famous professional football had
it not been for knee injuries we would
probably be talking about him as the
greatest player in NFL history um
unfortunately that did happen and he saw
that as a blessing which was very
strange but the book was about his life
and his relationship with a gentleman
named Brian Piccolo who later died of
cancer Gail's black Brian's white back
that in the 60s that was a really
interesting thing to talk about a
relationship like that um Brian Piccolo
later died they made a movie called
Brian's Song and that was based on this
book but that's not what I wanted to say
the title is I am third and what that
means is the Lord is first my friends
and family are second and I am third
and it's a very interesting take on the
Golden Rule but it's something that I've
dealt with it's been my motto my entire
life and I thank him tremendously for
that um while life can be challenging
it's infinite it is infinitely less so
because of the support that I receive
from so many people around me and
there's nothing that I could have done
in my life whether it's a church my work
my advocacy my authorship that I could
do without that and I'm really thankful
and with that um like to talk about
hb70 um just for your reference oh God
why does this happen here it is there is
an amendment to the bill which we'll get
to but as you know I wrote a book called
needless suffering um the good thing
that comes with writing a book that
actually has some level of popularity is
you get to travel all over the country
meet all sorts of really neat people and
do all sorts of neat things one of the
subjects in my book was the whole
concept of EA ronic medical records and
how I think they are a problem so you
know whenever you're experiencing
something a lot of times you think
you're alone that nobody else feels the
same way so one of the meetings I was
giving uh a talk before a bunch of
family practitioners and I thought I
should say something so I said if I had
my way I would take the alconic medical
record I would throw it to the bottom of
the ocean I would never bring it back
and leave it at that and I thought I was
get at Rotten Tomatoes thrown at me I
thought you know whatever quite the
opposite happened I got the first
Standing Ovation in my entire life
positive reinforcements so whenever I
gave that talk and I've spoken all over
the country I said the same thing and
everywhere I get the same response so if
that's the case then why do we keep
doing it and what's wrong with it and
that's what HB 7s designed to fix um as
you know some of you know this bill
passed by consent in this uh body last
year um this is something that's
bothered me a lot it went to the Senate
HHS um I was asked to put it to interim
study by certain people um I was told by
Senator Apprentice that the bill would
have passed without a question and and
had I not agreed to interim study it was
my understanding for you neo fites here
that the Senate actually did interim
studies they do not um um so the bill
functionally died with my um agreement
which really bothers me a lot with that
said we did talk over the summer and
that's what the amendment actually
addresses um as we proceed um I think
there's two principles that that guide
me that I think that we need to think
about first um and it's read along in
your handouts and your himels all right
I'm not going to go through all this
verbatim so it you know um but these two
are really important um I've been doing
medicine for a long time the first one
is the doctor patient relationship is
the most important diagnostic
therapeutic and human human human human
tool in health care any public policy
Intervention which adversely affects the
sanctity of this relationship should be
viewed skeptically and only supported
after an exhaustive review of risks and
benefits both intended and unintended
second this is really important for a
lot of things we're looking at in this
legislative session Private Practice
unencumbered by unnecessary oversight by
the medical industrial complex has been
the Bedrock of American Health care the
progressive destruction of this entity
intended or otherwise will be the
lasting and unfortunate Legacy of Health
Care reform it is my belief that the ahr
fails on both of those counts and that's
why I brought this bill forward I'm not
going to read the next part in 1981 I
engaged in a debate on pros and cons of
computers and health care and those
seven items that I list there are the
things that I said would un happen if we
went down this road every one of those
seven has has happened which makes me
function
Nostradamus
um it didn't really need to be this way
um in 2004 State of Union President
George W bush proposed the electronic
health record by saying that we can
avoid dangerous medical mistakes reduce
costs and improv care he was implying
that the EMR would be used to facilitate
communication between providers it
didn't turn out that way with the
creation in 2009 of what was called
meaningful use that we jokingly call
meaningless use by by uh CMS and later
Chang the name of U managing
interoperability which I have no clue
what that means but it means something
to them um they thought that I don't
know what they thought they were doing
but what we do know now is that the
intent was not to facilitate
communication to not improve patient
care but actually to facilitate maximal
billing and revenue and collect data for
public health and other professionals
it's not it's actually not facilitated
communication which is a
problem um I will not get into the
adverse effects on providers um Dr
Colligan who is speaking later we'll get
into that she's way smarter than that
about than I am about that but um we'll
talk about that later the other thing
that bother me is when CMS introduced
this they told us that we we could do it
if we wanted or not but if we chose not
to do it they would withhold 15% of our
fees so if Medicare they will withhold
15% if you don't comp comply and um I
personally as as a doctor um am insulted
by that and that's basically what killed
private practice is because they had to
give this incredible technology
investment um to to comply with that
that's another long story the only other
thing I'm going to read is the next
statement um it comes from Eric toppel
um he's uh um the founder of scripts
Institute which looks at translational
stuff he's very smart way smarter than
me about technology the good news is
both he and I and Dr Woods graduated
from univis of Rochester med school so
he's obviously very smart um but he said
the following um I think that the
electronic records have been the
singular biggest disaster in the last
two decades of healthc care the idea was
right but the execution has been pitiful
they are set up for billing purposes
which I said they couldn't care less
about the patient Centric Vision which I
said violation of both principles
they're pathetic they're the worst
software in existence that I know of
they've really taken us astray and have
given the whole digital area in
healthcare a bad name they've un
uniformally hated by patients and
doctors because they involve such poorly
performing user interfaces under the
single worst part of the deteriorating
doctor patient relationship I didn't
need to say anything else all I had to
do was read that because he's way
smarter than me um needless to say and I
will leave this to Dr Colligan to
discuss pH it's one of the leading
causes of physician burnout and we're
dealing with healthc care shortages
doctors especially that's a common
reason why do doctors go into
Specialties and not private primary care
because they can't afford to that's why
and that's why we have shortages hb70 is
a solution to a very real commercial
insurer problem all federal insurers
mandate EMR compliance even though they
technically don't but they just hold
back your money if they don't if you
don't as of now um I'm pleased to say
that local commercial insurers do not
require this and they're going to say
that this is a solution in term looking
for a problem I call it an ounce of
prevention we're witnessing an
unprecedented oopz of Health Care and
health insurance in this country and
there's virtually nothing to stop Mega
insurers from following the lead of CMS
which has always been the rule whatever
Medicaid Does Medicare does private
insurance follows mcos representing New
Hampshire Grant Advantage Program have
more than imp IED this at public
hearings where they referred to it as a
carrot and a
stick um anyways I've said most of that
I believe personally that this will
create a
Renaissance of Private Practice and
dramatically improve the quality of
healthc care decreasing cost increasing
access and improving efficiency with
that said I'm going to hand this out to
you guys a little old
lady her virtually nothing
and all it does is say what her problems
are what her allergies are what her
surgeries have been color coded
plasticizes and she handed to me in two
seconds I knew everything I needed to
know about her takes me hours to figure
out from an electronic record if I ever
do know what's going on with that
patient which is really a sad statement
and when we're thinking cost benefit
because that's really important here the
people that I'm really watching out for
here is it may be that doctors you know
alpath doctors are a lost cause that's
sad but it may be however a lot of what
we're trying to do is bring other people
into the fold acupunctur
chiropractors U massage therapists other
uh people that provide a valuable Health
Care Service we want them involved you
know what I hate about them when you
look at them they're all smiling they're
happy when I look at doctors they're
miserable and I go why are you happy
smiling is I don't have to deal with
insurance companies it's Wonder and I
said well why do you want to deal with
insurance companies they all say the
same thing gives me access to patients
that need my services so what I want to
do is I want to protect them from going
down the same mess that doctors went
down for that they don't have to make
this humongous investment in technology
that'll make them prone to being you
know going down the same uh corporation
that doctors have gone through the last
major comment I will make is that the
fiscal note on this bill really bothers
me a lot the electronic record has been
unnecessarily and excessively
costly this is a reason to lower cost
for them to even suggest that it's going
to increase cost to anybody in the long
term really bothers me a lot because
it's just not true um the bill itself
has three parts I Define EF EMR the
second part's a series of things called
private um umor provider protection all
the amendment does is it puts in the
words um let's see or any other
information required for the purpose of
obtaining prior authorization that's all
it adds um and the reason why was
because of our discussion the insurers
were concerned that they wouldn't be
able to get the data they needed for
that and I thought that was a reasonable
thing to add what we did remove last
year was the patient protection portion
that we're dealing with
separately um with that said
we have a job to do our job is to put
the needs of others at or above our own
that's what healthc care is all about or
what it should be about when something
gets in our way it needs to get be
eliminated and that's what the purpose
of this bill it's not to eliminate the
Emar but maybe take a step way back and
try to make it what it was supposed to
be in the first place something that
actually is cost effective and
facilitates communication that's what
the purpose to this bill was I hope you
can support it and thank you I'm ready
for any questions representative
palazov thank you Mr chair thank you for
introducing uh this bill uh what would
you think about some Sunset Amendment
because uh if this bill is addressing
issue uh that might be fixed uh in the
future uh for example if uh CMS rules
they start that started in 2009 not so
long ago if there will be reversed or if
there will be some better it system for
EMR introduced that will be producing
like a single view what happening in
this patient so maybe like in a year or
two or in three years maybe we won't
need this law anymore so what I have
thoughts on that you actually brought up
a point that I kind of forgot to make
number one there is a precedent for this
bill um I'm not directly answering your
question I'm being a politician and
answering it a separate way um last year
I passed the prior authorization bill
that I wrote with a bunch of other
people like a hundred other people and
um that bill actually did create
separate formats for filing prior
authorization that you could do it
either electronically or not so
basically this is doing the same thing
I'm not against the concept of EMR like
one of my friends is an acupuncturist
and she has a incredibly cheap EMR
system that works really well for her if
you can do it cheaply and and
efficiently but not having interfere
with what your interaction with the
patient is then it's fine I personally
have a no computer rule there are no
computers allowed in a patient room ever
and the reason why is cuz I just don't
want something to get between me and
them and that's why I don't wear a
weight coat for the same reason I don't
want something get between me and them
that's never going to change um drct oh
God I can never remember how to say his
name um sorry Dr
toppel um he's of the belief that
artificial intelligence um will solve
all of our problems which I think gets
to what you just said um um excuse me
for being skeptical um I I just I don't
believe that
um every patient in individual and
artificial intelligence will never ever
substitute for our
Humanity does that answer your
question you also represent
representative Lucas and then
representative
lontine thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my question this is a would
would you believe question would you
believe that over a very brief period of
time I had to learn five different emrs
reflecting three different Hospital
Systems my My Own Private Practice in
the clinic where I taught that required
attending seminars over weekends taking
time away from family that I didn't have
to begin with and there's one other
thing about the Advent of EMR that
greatly troubled me and you touched on
it I was horrified when I began to see
medical students and residents who spent
more time looking at a screen than they
did making eye contact when they would
ask patients questions about their
symptoms answer that with a would you
believe
would you believe that I'm I created a
program at the University of Rochester
to focus on the teaching of Dr patient
communication with regards to pain
management but when I asked them I said
how do you guys deal with and they said
our job is to teach them how to interact
with patients and that's what we do the
computer can come later and I'm very
proud that my University still does that
so thanks for bringing that up that's a
horrible problem you mentioned
representative lontine
thank you Mr chair and um thank you
representative Nagel for being here and
for this Bill I'm wondering though with
given the um concentration of Health
Care businesses like in my area Mass
General Brigham has bought up the
hospital just about every Private
Practice how if they have their own
medical record how how anyone that has
to interact with that
Network can um not also have to
participate in their medical record
system I'm looking more broader a lot
broader than that I mean if an
institution chooses to use that for
their own thing like for example you
know I interact regularly with Dartmouth
I interact regularly with the VA we
don't interact with our systems at all
um and they're not I mean the VA system
is horrible I don't care what they say
it's horrible I think dartmouth's system
is not a whole lot better um when I get
records from them it takes me forever to
figure out why the patient's even there
you know what we used to
do we used to actually call each other
and we would call the doctor up and say
this is what I'm I'm why I'm referring
the patient to this is what I need from
you we called each other the mo the the
most the least frequently used app on my
phone is my phone now but back then it
was and and and there's some wisdom to
that because personto person
communication is way better than
electronic communication especially when
you're dealing with complex issues like
this so um I'm not really persuaded by
that argument if they want to do that
that's certainly their business again
I'm really worried about chiropractors
acupuncturists and massage therapists
and people like that who've not been
forced down to go down this road to
allow them to have you know to be able
to focus on what they do best I mean um
I'm always jealous of them because they
not just cuz they're happy but they do
what I wish I could do you know I don't
know if that answered your question but
I the other little Minor Detail that's
relative to what you just said that we
need to be really worried about um um I
work with the Department of Healthcare
economics the University of Rochester
and one of the things that I've heard
before he wasn't the first person to say
this is that within 10 years we will
have an oligopoly
of
um insurers and health care providers in
this country we're already seeing that
happen in this state
CMC and um you know I personally think
these are incredibly dangerous
precedents and um I think that we need
to do anything that we can do to stop it
and one of the things that we really
need to do is promote for an advocate
for Private Practice because I'll be
honest we did much better than that
we're doing now that's my
opinion anyways representative pmer did
do you have your hand up
yes thank you Mr chair um so I mean what
I've lived most of what you've just said
and I agree
with 99% and the only concern I have is
this so um we just had a a local
practitioner who maintained his private
practice until he I think he just
retired and he was either 98 or 99 and
he only got a fax machine you know 5
years ago but the only the so the main
concern I I have and I think you know
most people he he did answer the phone
um most
people he had access to the Dartmouth
system so when his patients went to
Dartmouth and saw the cardiologist he
could look look that or rather his
secretary could look it up for him and
print it out so he could see what
happened and I just want to be reassured
that nothing in what you're proposing
here would stop that and and the other
thing is that somehow if if my patient
goes to a another practitioner that we
have a way to get that information to
our chart probably a faxed copy that
gets scanned in but that's that would be
my only concern just cuz yeah cuz I in
the old days you would see a patient in
followup and you wouldn't be able to you
know they they went to see the
neurologist and that report wouldn't be
there and it would be a wasted visit now
I that almost never happens so back in
my day like in our day when we were
young we always had the records we we
didn't need a statute to say you have to
send a record I had no trouble if a doc
referred me a patient I'd get something
in the mail or whatever it happen right
away but would you believe that I only
agree with my wife 70% of the time so if
you agreed with me 99% of the time I'm
not sure if our relationship is really
ready for that
but I I if we agreed on everything that
would be and and again there's two other
comments that I wanted to make one was
that um I have no problem with an EMR
like I love our EMR acopa like it's it
looks the same as the record we used to
use it's you know it's not in paper form
but it's the same format when a doctor
writes a note that's where you do your
thinking and if you have to stick your
notes in a template that's what most of
these emrs do then all of a sudden is
where does the thinking go you know and
and and I I asked eopa also um you know
the 15% thing I asked him how much does
it cost us to comply with that
15% and I couldn't get a good answer but
I said if it's more than 15% why are we
even complying at all you know um but I
love RMR but apparently now we have to
change it and we're going to follow
everybody's lead which bothers me a lot
but that's
life representative Woods oh thank you
Mr chair and thank you for listening to
uh me the old dinosaur as you
ref um uh yes for people who gather we
we did practice in the same office I
retired Liv years ago and I was not
faced with that um I did all my activity
face to face um having said that and
referring to the what I interpret as the
inevitability of the
EMR although we're trying to make some
changes es what in your mind is the
major impediment to
achieving an EMR that's meaningful and
I'll when you're done I'll offer my
thought can I say
greed so um you know when we start I
mean as President Bush had suggested
that was an honorable path to follow and
why we deviated from that path I have
absolutely no idea but um you know the
way it got designed was to you this
might have been after your time I don't
think so but you know was all the you
know you had to have so many bullets to
build for such and such a level the
whole EMR was designed to make sure that
you got enough bullets in to be able to
Bill a certain amount that's like
perverse but that is how it was designed
and then with meaningful use like every
time you go to your doctor and you ask
are you wearing a bicycle helmet do you
feel safe in your house is your gun
locked up all those questions those are
public health questions
that and I'm still never sure how that
public health information gets from my
EMR to them with and considering Hippa
and all that other stuff but some that's
why that data is being collected I was
at a a meeting of the national pain I I
was part of the national pain strategy
and there were like 200 docks in a room
and they're trying to figure out what
our problem is lack of data so they were
going to use this as a means of getting
meaningful use as a means of getting
more data so then they listed all the
questions that they wanted to add to
meaningful use and then I raise my hand
and I asked is there anybody else here
that actually practices clinically not a
single person raise their hand but me
and I said do you know what doing that's
going to do to my time with the patient
and it was kind of like Earth shattering
statement but it that is what it's
designed for just those two things if it
could be redesigned like RR is it
conquered
Ortho that it facilitates com
communication and that when you see the
doctors know you know exactly why the
patients there what their problems are
what their allergies are what their
surgeries are like that plastic thing I
just handed out that cost nothing my
wife did that for me yesterday that cost
me something do you want this back by
the way yeah I guess you can have it um
but um you know that's what I think the
EMR should
become I there there's you know and I
would say that greed is the big barrier
that we need to get
over follow up uh would you believe uh I
uh sort of agree in the sense of greed I
call it the corporatization of medicine
or the fragmentation of
medicine uh and would you believe that a
Single Payer would obviate a significant
part of this
problem and I submit an example and U
people here are not I'm sure you are
familiar with uh the Health Care system
in Singapore where you carry a card like
a driver's license and it's updated
every time you have an encounter
electronically and you walk in wherever
it is and you give them that and it's
put into the computer and every
absolutely every item is in place that's
an ideal
EMR um is that how you Invision that
transition not discarding the
EMR but this your bill is a step to gain
that
endpoint I would agree with that up to a
point this is my
concern um you know the type patients I
deal with I deal with patients that have
really complex disabilities I deal with
patients that are stigmatized on a
regular basis
um they don't their their problems don't
lend themselves to an easy diagnosis so
doctors will throw all these little
diagnoses in there but the one I hate is
opioid dependency when I have a patient
that's being managed successfully on
opioids and one doctor only takes one
puts opioid dependency on that gets in
their problem list and you know how hard
it is to get that out of that problem
list and that person is now further
stigmatized forever I had one patient no
lie all they got was volume for an MRI
and somehow that got translated in
anxiety disorder that was 10 years ago
an anxiety disorder is still on their
medical record and we can't get it off
that was the whole person of the purpose
of the third part of this bill which we
took off which was the patient
protection portion is we needed to find
a way to do that if you can figure out a
way to make it adaptable so that when
the information on there is wrong when
it tells you exactly what they're there
for when we're not serving somebody
else's needs other than the patients if
we can do all those things then that's
great but I think we need a dramatic
reset to do that and I'm not convinced
AI is going to help that um I I
I'm not
convinced other qu representative
hartnet I'm sorry to take all your time
keep going I'm sorry this is fun for me
thank you Mr chair good to see you
representative Nagel thanks um
appreciating uh this bill let's assume
that it
passes um what do you imagine might be
the kind of next generation of
legislation that would follow
this I I'm not I'm I I believe
personally that legislation is too often
and unne necessary evil I think that um
this this is
a a start a shot across the bow maybe
but I really think that what we're doing
at the state and we've done this with
other things the prior authorization
Bill we passed a bill a couple years ago
on opioid dependency and morphine
milligram equivalents that set a stage
for change all over the country and
that's kind of like the way I look at
this it's got to start somewhere and you
know yeah the commercial industry is a
right this isn't a problem in our state
right now um at least as far as they're
concerned but it could be but at the
same point with prior oth not only did
we make a change there but we made a
change with CMS too you need to have
both of those things happen and and then
all of a sudden you know a little Ripple
little Pebble becomes a big Ripple and
that that to me is what I'm trying to do
here the sad part is when you travel all
over the country and get the same
Standing Ovation for saying the same
stupid thing everywhere that's a problem
that people need we need to do something
about so that's what I Envision next
steps is we take this
Federal um and I actually already met
with our legislators in Washington to
talk about that um so it's it's it's a
start I used to have a friend that
directed HHS in Washington and we had
started that discussion but you know
like those jobs aren't there forever you
know so any other
questions representa
okay thank you Mr
chairman
U I don't know how to ask this question
but uh
I'm I'm concerned about the state
telling doctors how
to uh structure their records but I
wonder do they do the same thing
for the changes that have help happened
like there are nurse practitioners there
are uh chiropractors there are social
workers there's all kinds of people uh
who see patients who keep records are
they
required uh to follow state law and and
if you have any opinion as to why
Physicians have been uh pointed out um
anybody that participates with CMS in
any way shape or form has to participate
if you participate with the Managed Care
organizations in the state through the
granite state Advan Medicaid Program you
have to participate if you have to
practice through Medicaid you have to
participate if you're strict fee for
service direct care whatever term you
want to use to call it you you don't
have to so it's just them but anybody
like if I'm a chiropractor and I build
Medicare I got to part I have to do this
yeah I mean I don't have to but they're
going to withhold some of my salary
that's all followup
followup would you consider legislation
to eliminate this state
requirement I'm you know what's funny we
apparently don't like
mandates so we got a mandate so if we
don't like them maybe we should get rid
of it I don't know I I I I think that
you need you know when you practice
medicine you really need to figure out
what you need to do to interact best
with your patient first you know the
other people around you second um and I
think you need to make that individual
decision I don't think it's right for
somebody to tell you I personally think
if CMS wanted to do it this way it
should have been a 15% reduction they'll
give you 15% more you know it's positive
reinforcement not negative and I I think
that would have been a better way to
have done this but um um I you
know yeah I don't I'd have to think
about that that's a good
question tune in later thank you Mr
chairman for allowing my call um so
representative Nagel are there other
states with similar legislation number
one and number two uh what is the
position to your knowledge of any of the
medical uh uh professional associations
on this on this view so um to answer
your first question no I really enjoy
being a voice crying in the wilderness
and that is what this is um secondly
last year I haven't I never approached
them this year because um but last year
the medical society and the hospital
Association did support this um the US
pain Foundation supports this the
Chiropractic organization the state
supports this the acupuncture
Association the state supports this I've
not talked to the massage people and the
psychology people did support it last
year I did not do my due diligence to
get their approval again this
year other questions
I think that's it do you want this
representative Nel sure my wife would
appreciate very creative and a lot of
work went into it and I'm not sure what
I'll do with it
so thank
you thank
you I'm sorry to take so much of your
time last year this put five
minutes also signed up to speak is
Sabrina Dunlap from Anthem Blue Cross
and Blue
Shield good morning Mr chair and um
members of the Health and Human Services
committee thank you for the opportunity
to speak my name is Sabrina Dunlap I'm
senior director of government relations
for Anthem we are opposed to sb70 for a
number of reasons I believe all of which
I've discussed with rep Nagel we've had
some very good discussions about this uh
this bill and it's true in general we do
think the as a solution in search of a
problem as rep Nagel noted CMS led the
charge on EMR um it was not commercial
carriers and so we did not create the
current world of electronic records
we're just living in it um and so you
know notably we do not force providers
to use EMR many do but to the extent we
and providers do use EMR we need to be
able to use it properly um and one of
the major problems with this bill is it
restricts how we use EMR and in in the
cases where we're already using it uh
and so what I mean is the Restriction of
requiring only certain data particularly
in section D is at odds with reality um
there are some situations where we may
need more information to process a claim
for example um and I appreciate the
amendment which I just saw I think it
improves that language I don't think it
solves the problem entirely
um so I
think I think that the bills attempting
to do something I I appreciate sort of
the Grievances about EMR um I think
trying to sort of turn back the clock on
EMR but instead what the bill will do is
limit our ability to do basic functions
with providers when they are already
engaged via electronic medical record um
and that is quite problematic from a
logistical perspective um so I think
that's it and I'm happy to take any
questions and thank you very much for
the opportunity to speak okay thank you
any question questions representative
Lucas uh do you foresee uh should this
bill become law any um withdrawal of
insurance coverage from a state that has
this
law thank you for the question I want to
make sure I understand you mean like
what a carrier leave the state and no
longer provide yes thank
you that is a good question um I don't
know I don't I don't think so I think
that um
in general this would be moving New
Hampshire in the wrong direction I mean
I think the horses out of the barn on
this it was over 20 years ago um that
CMS started with emrs and so it is the
norm um I think when we compare New
Hampshire to other states where Anthem
does business New Hampshire does have a
lower adoption of EMR but is still quite
High I believe it's like over 80% um but
I do think this creates some serious
logistical and practical problem s for
carriers um so I don't know if that
answers
question other questions representative
mark alen thank you for taking my
question um how do you respond to
representative Nagel's uh proposition
that this may be the the additional cost
this may be a prime reason it's driving
people out of Private
Practice electronic records are driving
people yeah thank you for the question I
I mean I think I understand uh the
concerns coming from providers I mean I
have providers who seem to like
electronic health records um so I guess
it depends on the practice but I guess
to that issue I would say I don't think
this bill does anything to address that
if it's a grievance with
EMR I just don't see how this gets at
the issue because this is a scenario
where we're already using it where're
providers are already engaged with us
via EMR and then it only restricts
health insurance companies and how we
can engage with the providers so that I
think is the problem with the way the
bill is written okay thank you thank you
other questions representative
palazov thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh uh could you
clarify if you remember what
specifically in the amendment uh can
improve this bill because if I see
correctly the amendment
actually um adds to the list so I'm not
completely
sure thank you so um talking
specifically about section D and the I I
think that the amendment helps because
it adds any other information required
for purposes of obtaining prior oth but
we use and providers use EMR for a wide
range of of issues including claims
processing um and so I just think D is
not broad enough um and it just gets at
the heart of the problem which is if we
are engaged via EMR we have to be able
to use it
properly other questions representative
Woods thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh given that
this seems to be a f compete I.E the
medical record um and having served on
anthem's board in the early years when
they took over Blue Cross from Shield uh
they were not favorable in looking at
this issue has there been a change
noting that this will be something that
we appear to be living with do you sense
any
movement that there would be a honest
consideration to work with all the
players uh to try and make the medical
record more patient friendly not
business
friendly thank you for the question I
I'm not involved in our electronic
health record space um but my short
answer would be yes we would always be
happy to come to the table and and work
in a way that helps our members and
helps providers and I actually don't
know that's an interesting fact that if
I understood you correctly you're saying
that the carriers were not in favor of
the move yeah um that's interesting so
but yes I think we would be happy to
work with whomever to try to make the
system better
of just to encourage you to do so I was
uh when I served um for the American
Medical Association served on Council on
science and public health uh and a
special subcommittee we looked at this
issue in
2005 uh and because we could not get any
cooperation uh that it fell by the
wayside uh and that was the power of
Corporations but we would really like to
see this come to the four
again thank you for the question and
comment other questions
saying done say thank you thank you very
much also signed up to speak is Dr Ruth
hollan hello Mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is Ruth Colligan
and I live in conquer and I'm here in
support of House Bill 70 I'm a physician
an expert in patient safety and a
peer-reviewed research scientist in
human factors and in human factors what
we do is we study how people work in
complex safety critical systems like
healthcare much of my work was on the
impact of EMR implementation on
healthcare workers and I'm a bit of a
research
geek the the EMR is not all as cracked
up to be us of these systems incurs many
hidden costs especially with an ESP
special burden on small
practices first emrs actually increase
the documentation burden on
practitioners our study showed that for
every hour of direct patient contact a
provider spent two hours on the
computer this is outside of what we now
call pajama time which we did with a
diary study of Physicians who had to
work at home after they got their kids
to bed on their charting one and a half
hours at
home this type of burden is a
substantial component of practitioner
burnout next emrs are expensive to
adopt direct costs for a relatively
simple straightforward EMR are $150 to
$170,000 to
purchase just that's just to purchase it
then there's
$85,000 for implementation which means
getting it actually in the practice and
up and
running and $4 to 8,000 per year per
provider to
maintain these upfront costs push
independent practices to close or to
join up with bigger corporate Healthcare
and Hospital
Systems we call this vertical
consolidation and this is really been
shown to drive up consumer costs New
Hampshire patients
costs adoption of emrs pose a
disproportionate burden on small
independent
practices these practices are often the
lifeblood of primary care and
integrative
care I ask you to support New Hampshire
providers and support cour House Bill 70
thank you for the opportunity to speak
and um take any questions okay thank you
any
questions representative Woods uh thank
you Mr chair um not a question but do
you have some of that data I think
that's important uh for the committee to
know the overhead cost especially for
the independent practitioners corporate
practitioners is a non-starter because
they don't pay for it but we're talking
about the need for primary care they
tend to be smaller practice or
individual practices and that's where
the really the rubber meets the road
with this kind of difficulty if you
could provide those numbers I think it
would be very helpful I certainly can
and I I should state that I found these
numbers in
a in a pro EHR sort of sales rag that
was the only numbers I could find that
were up to date um other numbers were
back
from 2010 20 um 15 so those were out of
date you'll see those numbers often
quoted but they're wrong they're out
they're
old yeah other
questions seeing none thank you thanks
thank
you also signed up to speak is Peter
bragon from Harvard
Pilgrim Bron
good morning you've asked for five
minutes if you could keep closer to
three I'd appreciate it I will do my
best uh thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Peter bragon I'm a senior policy adviser
at predy strategies in conquer uh here
today representing Harvard Pilgrim
Healthcare New Hampshire's not for
profit health insurance carrier uh and
here opposed to House Bill 70 and uh
this is a bill we've seen before and uh
I start off by saying I always feel bad
uh testifying against one of represented
neel's bills because although we will
sometimes disagree on things as health
carriers and health providers um his
perspective on thing from someone on the
ground uh and the work that he does is
is very um enlightening so um disagree
with that and I'll start by saying too
that I can understand a lot of things
that were said by Dr Nigel and uh Dr I
forget the woman's name that just spoke
um so my my career uh was in uh I have a
degree in computer science uh out of
college I started a uh Consulting and
software company uh one of my first
clients was in New Hampshire Medical
Society uh actually oddly enough um but
then uh developed software that ended up
um putting us on the Inc 500 list of
fastest growing companies in America um
and I always told people that the
easiest part of developing any software
system is actually developing the system
the hardest part and the thing that
you're going to spend two-thirds or more
of your time on is making it so someone
else can use it and from all I've heard
uh the testimony these EMR systems that
are out there uh didn't take into
account the the perspective of the
person that actually has to use it I.E
the client uh so I can understand a lot
of the problems there and I will say and
later on I'll I'll say there are
benefits to the use of electronic
medical records uh but our position is
in opposition to this um for a number of
reasons one uh we don't think it will
accomplish what the sponsor wants if you
look at line8 and N of the bill
basically says that only state regulated
Health carriers uh are subject to this
law uh only about 30% of the New
Hampshire health insurance Market is
State regulated carriers you have
Medicaid you have Medicare you have the
VA you have Tricare you have large
self-insured company all sell all
subject to Federal Regulation not State
regulation so the 800 pound gorilla in
the health insurance Market is the
federal government and they are the ones
that are requiring providers to use
electronic medical records or
at this point maybe they're not
requiring but as the Dr Nagel says if
you don't use them they take 15% away
from you so they are essentially forcing
people coercing people to use electronic
medical records um Dr Nel said he
repeated my line from last year uh what
was it's a solution in search of a
problem line 10 uh says we can't require
a healthcare provider to use electronic
medical records we do not require
Healthcare Providers to use Med
electronic medical records nor do we
have plans to require them to do so nor
nor do we know of any other insurance
State regulated insurance carriers in
New Hampshire that require providers to
do that or intend to provide uh
providers to do that um line 11 says is
that is that for me
yeah you want to start wrap start
wrapping up you got something yeah I
understand I I so uh so um line 10
something we don't do anyways uh line 11
something we don't do anyways it would
be unw workable line 12 talks about not
requiring a specific format there are
formats required under levels higher
than us to allow these things to to to
communicate I have a good friend whose
mother is suffering from cancer and
hearing the stories about how the
pharmacist and the oncologist and the
radiologist and the and the primary care
provider can all work together and see
all the data in front of them is a very
important benefit to this so we
certainly encourage people to use it we
like it when people use it but we also
understand New Hampshire is a rural
State there were a lot of small
providers there are a lot of specialty
providers you know people doing
acupuncture and chiropracty they're not
going to be prescribing drugs it's not
going to be things that require the use
of electronic medical records so this
bill uh it it's not something that's
happening now it's not needed if you
implement it especially lines 12 and 13
saying that you can't have requirements
for how it works that who to say someone
hires someone to build a an electronic
medical record for them uh that doesn't
communicate with anybody else that
defeats the whole purpose of the EMR so
the bill has it stands is unworkable and
really unnecessary because we're not the
ones doing this it's CMS that's doing it
and that's where the fight should be
taken thank you happy to take any
questions any
questions seeing not thank you Mr thank
you no one else has signed up to speak
on on um hb70 FN does anyone else wish
to
speak seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on this bill uh 7 hb70 FN
uh the next hearing will be at 10:30 on
HB 731 FN which is in about 5 minutes so
we'll be in recess until then
thanks for
SM
e
e e
spor on the bill and this bill is just
one small step we were hoping to take um
to help a particular type of housing for
people with disabilities and it's to
clarify exemption from
lure um and we felt the the bill was
needed to correct a misunderstanding in
the way that bit of Statute was
interpreted and as the bill bill now
reads without the bill it's simp that
one section A facilities which are
operated for the continuing care of one
person or three or fewer persons in a
facility certified by the Commissioner
of Health and Human
Services and I'm going to talk about a
little bit about one situation I I know
well to help you help you understand the
certification for PE for a place with
just three people or
fewer um and that's I think it'll just
help understand because I found myself
explaining this to other people U
because my stepdaughter lives in such a
facility um which is a house and she
lives with her boyfriend both of them
have Down
syndrome and they live with two home
care providers so there's no more than
two clients Under One Roof the healthc
care providers are paid through
Community Partners and they provide
oversight for the home care providers
and
support and Eliza and Shane also reive
services from other um outside agencies
and they have each have their own uh
independent case manager so in this case
the whole house does not need to be
licensed it's just certified by Health
and Human Services for basic things to
make sure it's a safe place for them to
live um but this there are drawbacks to
this Home Care providership model and
that there tends not to be a permanent
housing
solution now Eliza is lucky that um my
husband and I were able to buy a house
and Rehab it for this purpose but most
people with disabilities don't have a
father who's a contractor who could pull
that
off so because of the lack of permanent
Housing Solutions for people with
disabilities uh there are a lot of uh
parent Le groups across the street state
that are trying to set up new
Solutions because many of the parents
are getting older and they now have
adult children still living with them
with their with
disabilities and they're thinking what's
going to happen the in the future for my
child we need to come up with some other
Solutions and there are two concepts
that are being pursued by several groups
across the state and one the res stents
will live in separate
apartments under the same roof or maybe
separate buildings but they share a
common space and the entity which is
typically a nonprofit formed by these
parents um The Entity would manage the
facility and also hire
staff who some of them might be
providing Transportation or helping to
prepare food but that usually would have
one person there
247 um the other model whatever
percentage of Apartments set aside for
people with disabilities and say a new
um large apartment building that's being
built through the affordable housing
Fund in which there could be Workforce
housing a lot of people could live there
but
25% of the units would be set aside for
a person with disability I
ities and there may be um two or up to
three people sharing the apartment
within this larger building but the
difference there is that the nonprofit
May own the building but they're not
providing all these comprehensive
Services directly there'll be an outside
agency that is providing
them
and um they may provide May ride meals
or not and may engage in other community
activities but their residents would
still live independently so those are
the two
models that we were hoping with this
bill to try to clarify the statute so
that ideally they might be exempt from
lure and only be
certified
however we amended the bill which I
brought forward to
you um at the request of dorine chakle
at um Health and Human Services who felt
that the original bill was not
accomplishing what we wanted it to
do um and it was also probably not um
legal as well so this is very
disappointing for um some of the people
that we've been working with and trying
to come up another another solution
because it looks like it would only help
the model of the apartment building
in which no Direct Services are being
provided by that
nonprofit that got the thing built now
other people that are here might be able
to explain some of this a little better
but I'm trying to sort of break it down
to see what our goals were and what the
bill can or cannot do um and it may
be that we bring another amendment
forward again before we exec the bill
because um some people felt like we
could have tweaked it a little more we
might actually making more making things
harder than not better
um
and what
else and I would say like there's
nothing the first model that this bill
or the amended
Bill uh we you know we'd like to help
it's a great model and it might be
though it still might have to be
licensed even if we would like to say oh
it could just be certified but given the
comprehensive nature of the services
provided um and that is all done by one
entity in which the resident doesn't
really have a choice about who's
providing these Services they may have
to be licensed maybe we can't fix that
problem we're still trying to work on it
um but we hope that you will support the
bill and we can try to come up with the
best amendment to fix this problem by
the time we have to execute um and then
we could move forward in a more you know
streamlined fashion the other the other
solution is that we try to work on Ru
making so
that if there's no way around having to
be licensed we can try to make
lure um as least costly and easy to do
as
possible so um and the other thing is we
hope that you will support the bill and
help these groups to overcome the
biggest obstacle they have which is
financing but that's a matter for
another bill before other committees but
just to keep that in
mind and that's
it thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
bringing this bill forward to us I just
have a quick question um where it says
such units shall meet certification
standards established by can you just
give like one or two examples of what
would be involved in certifying these
units the only one I can speak well was
why I brought up the home care
providership with um where my
stepdaughter lives well they check to
make sure the smoke detectors are
current and are inspected annually they
make sure that the residents have
regular fire drills they make sure the
place is is a safe and
secure home that's most of what
certification is in that
situation
um
yeah other
questions representative
kofo thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so I'm trying to
understand the the distinctions between
the amendment and the original bill as
filed and I'm looking at the amendment
at the moment um the Bold italic say
this exemp also applies to buildings
that provide residences to both
independent individuals and individuals
receiving services pursuant to RSA 126
a19 and
20 it then says that it also applies to
any entity that provides housing to
three or more three or more individuals
receiving services pursuant to those um
sections provided that the entity does
not provide or arrange for personal
assistance so what I'm struggling with I
mean generally I like I I really like
the idea of um sort of dialing back and
clarifying some of the regulations yeah
I'm just struggling to understand sort
of the there sort of a confusing mix of
what would be exempt and what would not
be exempt and so uh both for my own
edification and so that we have it
clarified on record uh show the courts
ever need to uh look at this it would be
helpful to me to understand almost like
a a matrix or a list of bullet points of
which scenarios are Exempted under this
amendment and which are not I'm more
concerned about the amendment that I am
with yeah the original bill because I
sort of assume that you're bringing
forward the amendment with the intention
of addressing the concerns that you
raised so um do you have that kind of an
analysis or could you provide that kind
of an an analysis to us um at some point
F the hearing um and you're not alone in
feeling that way and and um actually and
Dorene shley is here who really helped
draft the amendment because when she
looked at the original language that
this isn't really going to work it's not
going to do what you want but the best I
understand it now is saying that you
know provide residents to both
independent individuals and individuals
receiving services pursuant to and that
is the other whole section about types
of services provided to people with
disabilities so in that scenario it's
the apartment building where there are
people that aren't getting any services
but say we have 25% set aside for people
who are um but I I think it's um and I
did want to
clarify with many of the stakeholders
that well it can mean that you're still
providing um some Community meals and
and movie night game night a lot of
activities but any specific um like
medicals services or a personal
assistant that helps someone that has
mobility issues or
Transportation they would be have have
to be provided by another agency not the
entity that owns the
building is the difference but we can
try to break it
down and
um dorine chuley is also here if you
want to ask her more specific questions
I'll set any question any other
questions representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman uh I'm I'm very interested in
this
subject uh
however there are all kinds of housing
problems there's mentally ill there are
people coming out of prison there are
people with developmental disabilities
there's all all kinds of of extremely uh
needy
populations I'm trying to figure out how
to not get these different groups
competing with each other for
services and have a united
front uh I I'm a landlord who does I
have four apartments in my house
and uh I I don't want to say too much
because it would deal with people's
identif
identity uh but there are very
complicated problems for
landlords uh who do try to
help uh so that
uh what I'm saying to you just
complicates the problem that you're
bringing to us uh but but I think it
needs to be considered because of this
is a major State policy
issue and one that I'm hoping we can go
at that deals with all of the issues and
do you have any
thoughts along the lines of this kind of
vague concern that I have
uh so it sounds like you're saying well
I provide housing for people that might
qualify for um special services provided
by someone
else um and are you wondering how much
um to what extent will your property
need to be certified for certain
things I think it should be I'm a a
licensed clinical social worker and and
I deal all the time unfortunately I've
ended up in court uh because of it uh
but most landlords are not in that
position that I'm in U well I I think
the key thing to understand is why in
some circumstances it should be okay
just to have certification is that many
of the other people that are helping to
take uh provide services for these
residents are licensed in their own
field they're licensed to to practice
what they do and so it's trying to avoid
having excessive lure when it's not
needed so
it's the chairman won't let me go on but
that uh if if he would we could spend
the whole afternoon I definitely don't
want to do
[Laughter]
that thank you Mr chairman you're
welcome any other
questions seeing none thank you
thanks also signed up to speak is
representative Kathy
stab is it stab or sto
or stab stab okay the German one
um thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is um
Kathy stabb and I'm a representative for
Hillsboro District 25 which is Ward five
in Manchester last year I had the
privilege to serve with the sponsor of
this bill on the study committee on the
impact of the housing crisis on people
with
disabilities we learned that there was
an overarching issue around the fact
that most people with disabilities have
limited income and there are not enough
units that are affordable for them
however we also learned that there were
issues that were specific to the
population with developmental
disabilities a few decades ago we turned
away from institutionalization for
children with developmental disabilities
instead they lived with their families
attended their local public school and
grew up as part of their communities as
a result we've learned what they are
capable of there continues to be a wide
range of needs some need 247 care but
others hold jobs volunteer socialize and
are active contributors to to their
communities most of them continue to
live with their parents who are aging
and that has the parents very concerned
the time has come for us to develop new
models of housing for adults with
developmental disabilities who need
varying levels of support the good news
is that the parents have stepped up in
are willing to use their own talents and
resources to leverage available funds to
create these new models of Supportive
Housing and this bill is the first step
in removing some of the barriers that
they have encountered and I hope you
will support this bill I mean for
example we've been talking about this um
mixed development um there is a specific
rule that um refers to people with
developmental disabilities saying that
no more than three people with
developmental disabil ities can be Under
One Roof so what that means is if you
have a 20 un apartment building and you
set aside five of those units for people
with developmental disabilities even
though there's only one or two people
living in each one of those apartments
that would mean that the entire building
would need to be licensed which means
the owner would have to fill out rings
of paperwork they would need an elevator
that would support a hospital gurnie um
and so the the cost of the development
of the of the building would be higher
and the um uh the level of paperwork and
other things that would be required to
maintain the building would also be
increased and and you know
for uh for you know this is this is
really loow hanging fruit here is to
just kind of remove that distinction so
that we can create these mixed
communities where people with
developmental disabilities can live in
the community be have access to
transportation and amenities and um um
and services um but you know and but and
and um and and not not force their
landlord to have to fill out rings of
paperwork and develop um um you know all
the building really as as a as as some
kind of a health care facility so that's
that's why we're looking at this it's
just one little thing sure any
questions representative palazov uh
thank you uh Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh
so um two parts like first to follow up
on uh representative cofal question
uh if there would be a further amendment
to this bill uh I I also would like to
see some clear list to understand like
like in Amendment I'm not sure if we are
talking about two types or three types
of facilities or four types so some list
would be helpful and question is you you
mention
affordability so do you have any
estimate
of uh this licensing cost burden how
much it adds um I do not um um there are
folks who have been working on
developing these kinds of um uh
facilities or these kinds of buildings
or um housing um developments who um
will come after me who have been
investigating this at at more in more
detail I
um I will send everyone the preliminary
report from our committee so you can see
um what kinds of information we
uncovered when we talked to folks um so
I do not have that information um and um
in terms of of of the cost um burden but
we did hear about it um in in terms of
the amendment um you know we have been
working with Duran sharle and I think
that she may come forward with some
ideas of how to clarify that but
basically the idea is that you know if
you're living if you're living in your
own apartment and you're bringing in um
outside agencies to um you know to
provide services for you whether it's
you know you you need help with take
your medications or you need help with
cleaning or whatever if that's being
done with an outside agency then that's
one class of housing that that will be
available and that's what this bill is
looking at um whereas you know the the
more complicated one is the more let's
call it
allinclusive um where you know you're
living in the building and all the
services that you need are being
provided by the owner of the building so
that's more complicated and and um joran
shley can probably provide more um
background into how complicated it would
be a lot of this um these rules come
come to us from CMS and you know we
don't want people to be in violation of
the rules that are coming from CMS about
people with developmental disabilities
when they're trying to provide housing
for people you know they they're they're
young they're they have jobs they have
lives they just you know they just want
to continue and their parents want to
make sure that once their parents are
gone that they're in in in safe and safe
and stable housing so that you know
they're not going to you know they they
want what we want for our kids they want
we want them to be safe we want them to
be happy and that's what we're hoping to
accomplish with um making this small
change to you know really kind of pick
off this loow hanging fruit that's
preventing people from building
appropriate housing for adults with
developmental
disabilities okay thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is lri
McIntosh from our place New
Hampshire thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for letting me
speak this morning um I did not bring
enough copies so I promise I will email
you all my testimony
um my name is Lori Macintosh I'm from
Dober New Hampshire I'm the chair of the
board of directors of our place NH it's
a nonprofit organization with a mission
to provide housing for adults with
intellectual developmental disabilities
or ID our place NH has purchased
property in Dober New Hampshire and is
planning to build Supportive Housing
Apartments for 11 individuals with ID
I'm speaking in favor of House Bill 731
which would make it possible for a new
model of housing for adults with ID to
be created in New Hampshire and I want
to shout out a big thank you to the
committee that worked on this the uh
committee to study the impact of the
housing crisis on people with
disabilities and the uh staff members
from DHHS who have worked with them
also our place New Hampshire has been
working with a developer from New York
and Jessica talked about this already a
little bit he's created large Workforce
housing apartments uh apartment projects
with 40 to 50 units and he reserves 25%
of the units for adults with ID within
each project there's a common area where
all tenants are invited for activities
such as art classes movie nights and
yoga this is a great way to facilitate
the inclusion of individuals with ID the
project also provides offices for
service providers within the building
the tenants with ID have 247 Staffing
and the services are provided to those
who choose to have their services
delivered by the agency in the
building House Bill 731 would help make
this type of project possible in New
Hampshire by amending RSA 151 colon 2
and allowing the individual units to be
certified for provision of services to
this population rather than requiring
licensing of the entire building this
sensible change will make it much more
costeffective for the developer there is
some language in the amendment to this
bill that I hope will be changed before
it goes to Executive session as the
wording implies that the tenants would
have to be on participant directed
manage services which is you'll have to
learn about that but there's different
typ of services in New Hampshire and the
amendment implies that people will have
um be
self-directed and that is not the how
the model the that I'm looking at works
so there is another model of budget use
which is called the hm11 budgets and in
those budgets you can combine services
so for instance if you have 10 people
living together they all pay on Tenth of
the overnight staff so you have to be
able to use these medic paid budgets
that are
combinable anyway HB 731 is a step in
the right direction um I'm disappointed
that this bill does not make it easier
for some of the smaller projects like
ours um that are existing or proposed
because we're going to have to jump
through the hurdles of Licensing um but
as someone else said ahead of me maybe
the the appropriate way to go is to work
on those licensing requirements to make
them a little easier for projects like
us um so please pass this Bill and I'm
ready to take any questions thank you
any questions representative Palazo
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question could you speak a little bit
about those licensing requirements uh
what they are as they add to safety and
what is estimated cost of complying with
those
requirements okay because we have not
actually developed our project yet I
can't give you exact numbers but I can
tell you that when you have to go
through
lure um there are there are a little
more stringent um demands for you know
fire uh safety things but not much we
have to have a sprinkler system I know
that um but there are some things that
were mentioned before like having to
have an elevator um some of the
licensure requirements like in a health
care facility you have to have toilets
that can hold up an 800 lb person um
many of these things you know could be
waved so working on the actual
lure um rules themselves might be able
to pair down some of those expenses um
the other thing is that
[Music]
um lure requires more documentation so
not only do you have to uh clean your
stove hoods over the stove every month
to make sure that the grease isn't there
but you have to have a notebook with a
chart in it that shows that you've
cleaned those stove hoods so somebody
has to be in charge of that so there's a
lot more documentation um required for
lure and that requires more
staff other
questions seeing none okay thank you
than
you also signed up to speak is Doren
shley from the Department of Health and
Human
Services been hearing a lot about you
from previous
speakers good morning chairman McDonald
committee members having heard my name
over six times I thought it might be a
good idea to come come up um I hadn't
planned on testifying but um I do
appreciate this opportunity very much
this morning and as has been said I've
worked very closely with stakeholders
across the state as well as the
committee um i' want to spend very brief
of time but I do want to let you know
that this conversation and if you're
feeling that this is complex and
difficult to kind of grasp it is um I've
been working on it with folks in the
community since December of 2022 so um
that gives you some some um information
as to how long this conversation has
been going on it was in 2023 that Lori
and her team came forward with a model
that they wanted to use in Dover um in
you've heard about that this morning um
25% independent folks and then um some
or just the opposite 25% are those that
are going to be receiving services and
the rest would be independent and as the
law is written now we would be required
to license that facility that Resident
um I encouraged them at that time to
seek a sponsor to change the law because
it's certainly not something the
department wants to have regulatory
oversight on a place where there's a
mixed use of um so that's why we're here
today um I've heard a couple comments
about the bill as originally written and
as originally written if you would um
look at line
nine leasable unit providing complete
and independent living facilities well
those don't need to be licensed now so
this bill was in fact accomplishing
nothing in terms of this population
which is why I then reached out to the
committee and said okay so based on the
feedback that we received through all
the sessions this is not accomplishing
what was originally intended therefore I
made some suggestions to the language
was which is what you're looking at in
the amendment um I do understand there
were conversations last night in terms
of maybe providing um a little bit more
clarity um which we are certainly
willing to do in terms of um it is our
position that this does in fact um it's
a small step but it's also a big step I
know that doesn't make sense um but
having worked on this for close to 3
years um I'm excited to see that we are
going to make some changes I hope that
we can amend the language somewhat um we
have more work to do unfortunately this
committee is engaged for another year
which is not ordinary it's usually one
year and we have two years and I've
already spoken to the State Fire
Marshall's office this morning they are
willing to engage in conversations to
carve out more of the larger
environments that may also want to be
exempt that um we don't want to do that
now because it will have unintended
consequences but once we engage with
local authorities and State Fire
Marshal's office we might be able to um
exempt
additional I think that's all I have do
you have any questions thank you uh any
questions representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman uh since you're from the
Department of Health and Human Services
I'm going to try again
I so there's no confusion I support this
legislation uh however it it's a larger
problem
than than the one that's addressed in
this
legislation and it's a it's a major
issue for our state there's no question
about it in terms of
housing it is there some way that the
department uh through the oversight
committee uh uh could begin to look at
this in a more
comprehensive way uh what I'm concerned
about is one group competing against
another and what we could have which
would be a
powerful issue would be support coming
from all of the these different groups
who
are uh in in conquered we have a very
serious housing problem and we just
recently uh shut down one of the uh
biggest um
homeless uh uh aspects in our city and
where those people go is beyond me uh so
I I would
uh as much as I support this I support a
larger concept that deals with all of
the aspects of our housing issue do you
have any comments um thank you
representative McKay um I failed to
introduce myself I am the um manager of
the Bureau of Licensing and
certification at the department and um I
I think it's important and I and you
rais a very important point and I and I
appreciate that I I think it's important
to note that the population of
individuals that we're speaking about
today are are already in the system at
the department in terms of the Bureau of
Developmental Services they're already
receiving services and we also certify
the housing which I think um
representative Lamont um described
there's a certification process um and
then there's a licensing process um in
terms of a more comprehensive way to um
deal with our housing crisis I think
um I certainly would believe that the
department would be certainly supportive
of that I don't know if there's already
is there a committee that's working on
that I don't know I think um
representative Missour is saying yes um
I would imagine that there is a
committee um I would be happy to
contribute to that to the extent that my
Bureau would be you know would have an
impact on that um I know this committee
was um focused um primarily on those
with disabilities and how the housing
crisis was impacting that population of
individuals I hope that answers your
question thank you representative plaz
off and then representative Woods uh
thank you Mr chair um if you could go uh
through the list and just help uh
understand what uh uh I counted four
types uh of uh um facilities here and um
like C second one is three or few few is
at a
certified but then line nine talks about
three or more
individuals so like I'm not sure if like
third type and fourth type
mentioned uh are they certified like so
if you could just like quickly go like
what kind of facilities this bill uh uh
affect uh in terms of a list okay thank
thank you
um so if I understand you want me to
describe what the amended bill is
accomplishing okay um first the bill
would amend RSA 151 colon 2 Roman 2A by
adding a license exemption for buildings
that provide residences to both
independent individuals and individuals
receiving services this is important for
the State of New Hampshire because there
already as we've heard structures that
fall within this definition like
apartment likee structures um and
currently those are those are requiring
lure so this bill would change that
secondly the bill would amend RSA 151
colon 2 Roman 2A by adding another
license exemption to any entity that
provides housing to three or more
individuals receiving Services provided
that the entity does not provide or
arrange for those personal assistance or
any health related um it creates an
exemption for entities that are
providing housing to three or more
people but but the individuals are
managing their own services this I
believe is language that last night in a
discussion was um um there was some
concern that the way that the language
that I suggested may be prohibitive so I
think there was some suggested language
that the department would absolutely um
um consider um we our our goal is to
help increase the exemptions so that
there's more opportunities not diminish
those resentative Woods thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh the original uh Bill uh had
no fiscal impact uh from what you've
described and what you anticipate some
changes uh could you comment uh on the
fiscal impact uh in general I obviously
you can't give details but uh would that
change dramatically or not um thank you
for the question representative Woods
the original as written Bill had no
impact because it didn't accomplish
anything um um I shouldn't say it didn't
accomplish anything sorry that was not
what I meant I meant it was they're
already exempt so it had no impact I
don't really see the second um with the
amendment will also if anything um it
would I mean I so I have two teams well
I have more than two teams but two teams
that would be impacted by this bill a
licensing team and the certification
team the certification team is already
working with all of these types of
entities um the the change would be that
licensing would not be so if anything
there would be less fiscal impact to the
department not
more other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on HB 731 FN does anyone else wish to
testify if there if none there is no one
then I'm going to close the public
hearing on this bill again HP 731 FN I'm
going to close the public hearing we
will be in recess until 11:30 at which
time will'll be hearing
hb17
e
e e
hello everyone and welcome back uh to
the house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs the next
bill scheduled to to be heard this uh
today is House Bill
117 Prime sponsor is representative
Erica Leon from markingham County
District
13 welcome representative
Lon thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee and uh hello again to all
of you I've served with in this
Committee in the past um I am here to
introduce House Bill
117 um which was originally brought
forward by another former member of this
committee representative Gary Merchant
um he is a pharmacist and was a former
chair of the New Hampshire Board of
Pharmacy and a very knowledgeable man in
this area this bill is actually a lot
more simple than it seems right now
there may be some movement in Washington
DC and the FDA to recognize what other
areas have always realized that there's
not really a difference between
interchangeable and biosimilar other
than a regulatory pathway that provides
some protect protection for the first
entrance into the market Market um when
you have a we have some other people
here that can talk to a lot of the
science on the biologics and biosimilars
so I'm just going to stay on the very
very top level of this uh basically
biologics are we're talking about large
molecules not little small molecules
like aspirin and we're talking about
things that are grown and not produced
um in a chemistry set so it's a
different process than generic drugs
generic small molecules and the
biosimilars are similar but not not
exactly the same as generics um so back
when I was an analyst uh covering some
of the big companies that make drugs
like Huma I was kind of worried for
investors about what was going to happen
with these biosimilars um there was a
program that came around that said that
when you have one of these drugs you go
and you do a pretty big test and you
switch people back and forth just to
make sure that they're not any different
the thing is in order for a biosimilar
to be approved at all you need to do a
lot of tests that show that you
statistically can't find a difference
between the original biologic and the
new biosimilar um this is a process
that's been going on for nearly two
decades and in Europe there was never a
difference between interchangeable and
biosimilars there's been quite a good
deal of guidance saying that there's not
not a difference between interchangeable
and biosimilar except in the US
regulatory scheme and I can send quite a
bit of information to anybody who really
wants to get into the details on this
but I also didn't want to fledge you
with papers um so at this point there's
been some draft guidance circulated by
the FDA that may um sort of change the
way that interchangeable drugs in
interchangeable biosimilars are treated
um we don't know when they'll act on it
because unlike the state of New
Hampshire the federal government doesn't
set time limits on when they need to act
on recommendations you know it'd be a
better world if they did but not
everybody can govern like conquered does
um so if the FDA decides that you no
longer need to have a switching study in
order to substitute biologics um it
wouldn't meet our current definition of
interchangeable products in the bill in
front of you on line oh I don't have
line numbers on mine but in section
three that would allow that if the FDA
adopts another way to have what is in
essence uh interchangeable biologic that
would allow the New Hampshire law to
adapt alongside With The fda's Changes
because right now our language could
lightly lock Us in and leave us behind
the times and this matters a lot for our
our constituents um I was actually
talking to one of my neighbors who is a
great guy I didn't really think I was
going to get into the science of
biologics with him but he was telling me
about how
lifechanging um some of these drugs are
for him and how expensive they are and
how the biosimilars have made a
significant difference in his life by
being able to not pay the Branded
price if we adopt this and if the FDA
makes the moves needed so that this
actually becomes effective for us here
in New Hampshire this would mean that if
you show up and you have the original
drug the the Gucci one whatever the
fancy one is that costs $1,000 a month
um you have the biosimilar that your
doctor wrote you a description for which
is biosimilar a that costs you $600 a
month and if you're pharmacist can get
you biosimilar B which right now only
cost you $200 a month or $400 a month
the pharmacist can talk with you and say
you know these are going to be no
different in your body when we've tested
them they're no different um they're not
they're not provably different and
they're no different than different runs
would be of the biologic so we can do
this and if you want to save this amount
of money we can switch you and there's
not going to be a difference in your
treatment because by definition a
biosimilar has that same effect um so
this would really Empower pharmacists to
help our constituents save money at a
time when we're all struggling and this
wouldn't move ahead of the FDA it would
just allow us to sort of drift draft
right along them if they change these
requirements we can follow right along
and implement it as soon as as soon as
they do that make that move move and so
I think the biggest part too is you may
end up hearing about some harms from
biosimilars um there's a great reporting
program 1800 bad drug if somebody tells
you that somebody was harmed by a
biosimilar the first question should ask
you should ask is when did you report
this to the FDA you can call 1 1800 bad
drug if somebody hasn't reported it but
they're telling you that about a about a
bad event a bad outcome I would question
that because if there's really a problem
the first people they should call it The
Regulators to help keep patients safe um
secondly the FTC and the FDA H are
working together to make sure that
there's not misinformation on biological
products um there's you may end up
hearing from people about something
called a nobo um it's like a placebo but
people are very afraid that when they
change from Blue to Red there's going to
be a noticeable noticeable difference
when there's not um when people who
should know better feed into that it's
problem and the FTC has said that that
may be anti-competitive in order to
spread doubt and concern about the the
clinical efficacy of these drugs um so
when I reviewed the comments on the FDA
the potential change in FDA guidance
where all you would need to do is
scientifically prove that they're the
same without having to put them through
people and change them uh because at
this point the science is there um there
were 28 people that SP that 28
organizations are people that provided
information a lot of the very highlevel
scientific and medical organizations
like the American Medical Association
and the American Society for clinical
oncology support the change because they
understand the science that we know with
the tests that we now have available
that weren't available 15 years ago when
this first happened they know that it's
going to not going to have a difference
in the human body and it's not going to
make a medical difference for patients
it'll just make a financial difference
because if you can't afford your
drug that could have life-ending
consequences for you um there were
there's different organizations a lot of
this is why the FTC is working with the
FDA to make sure that the information
that's presented is clear and convincing
and doesn't lead into fear and concern
when it should not exist uh because
goodness knows there's enough things we
need to worry about in this world we
don't need to add non problems to worry
about so with this
um I would ask for your support of this
bill because it allows us to move along
with medical and Regulatory Innovation
at the federal level when it comes
forward and uh it's the right thing to
do to impact Financial tesity so I'm
ready for any questions thank you
representative
wber thank you Mr chairman thank you for
bringing the bill to us and thank you
for taking my question
um and I just noticing on page two this
also includes a patient uh prerogative
sentence so if the patient informs the
pharmacist that he or she doesn't want
to wish doesn't wish to receive an
interchangeable biological product they
don't have to they can go with the
original and so it's up to the patient
to make the tradeoff
between the price how they feel what
whatever is go whatever else is going on
correct correct and um that may also
lead to us a patient deciding that even
if the one that's been prescribed isn't
available they'd rather just wait or
find a different Pharmacy because that's
their right um but if they wanted to
change they'd be able to okay thank you
other questions representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so bear with me
because I'm still trying to understand
so um
and I'm reading like you said lines 22
to 24 um
so do you is is the FDA working on that
already and what what exactly is the
nature of the change that they would
just say we're going to liens this
biological but we're not going to say
it's interchangeable who is going to
make that
determination that it meets the
definition of an interchangeable I'm
just trying to kind of are they where's
the definition coming from if it's not
you know what I'm saying so you could
just clarify and if they are working on
it how imminent do you believe it is uh
thank you for the question so there are
several different moving pieces back in
2009 they had the original legislation
that allowed for the the bio bio
similars um and allowed for some of the
transparency around it and when the the
FDA implemented this where if you had
the copy molecule or copy
um the copy biologic and you did a
switching study on patients if you ran
that did the switching study and
submitted for an interchangeable
designation nobody else could come up on
your heels and bring another bias
similar to market for a whole year so
you had onee Market
exclusivity which would help cover the
cost that it's really expensive to run
these trials at the time too they didn't
have the capabilities to analyze these
um outside of humans and do the assays
to make sure uh and make sure with
enough confidence to satisfy the FDA
that these really did act in the same
way so in the meantime there's been
advances in the way that they can assay
these and assess them outside of humans
um there's been movement um Senator Mike
Lee has introduced legislation on this
and there's been bipartisan support in
order to do this um I want to note that
um the only other legisl that I'm aware
of on biosimilars was when Senator
Hassan actually put one in about more
education to make sure that people are
appropriately educated on biosimilars
and the options and the fact um and
about their safety and about the
equivalency so the FDA has done several
efforts to do this right now they're
talking about the labels and the labels
they don't want to have a big
distinction between an interchangeable
label and a biosimilar label because
that difference and designation is
causing a lot of that hesitation and
it's causing people to perceive that
they're having a different outcome just
because they've gone from red to blue
they're working on some of the delivery
mechanisms because some of these are
shots and they're working to standardize
this so there's a lot of different
efforts within the FDA in order to move
past this transition phase where we had
interchangeable biologics um and move to
where the rest of the world is we a
biosimilar is a biosimilar is a bio ilar
uh the European uh medical agencies have
and the health leaders of Europe have
also put out a paper trying to deal with
the confusion around interchangeables
and biosimilars because while
interchangeables are a uniquely United
us creation um the concern that's been
raised about the difference between them
has actually led to a lot of patient
confusion even in Europe um so once the
FDA is able to move past this and and
move past this hurdle where they
required more very very expensive tests
in order to get Market exclusivity that
then also allows you to sell that one
for more money than you would if if
everybody and their brother was
introducing a bio similar um this is
going to really really reduce costs
there's now over 60 uh biosimilars that
have been approved in the US when this
bill was in front of Commerce last year
there were only 49 so this is something
that is absolutely exploding and it's
being done um it it's being done in a
way
that doesn't negatively impact Patients
health so um according this is this is a
little bit old it's from March 2020 but
back then um biological products were
only 2% of prescriptions but they
accounted for 42% of the total net
spending on prescription drugs in the US
which was up from 30% in
2014 and um at the time one of the
panelists was stating that about 40% of
new drugs are biological products with
60% being the small molecule what you
call a traditional drug so uh
biologics really are advancing medicine
for us these biosimilars are and um the
FDA they don't have a time frame um when
speaking with some of the industry
lobbyists that have spoken with the
lobbyists in DC the FDA doesn't have to
act on the draft guidance at any point
in time um I had thought that if this
was going to come in the summer then
maybe we hold on to it and wait and do
it after that but we don't know when the
FDA will act but if we pass this we're
ready and or poised and able to take
advantage of that change without moving
ahead of them follow
up just a quick follow because I'm
really trying to understand so it sounds
like that they have uh they're loosening
up on uh the testing methodologies that
would allow you to to no he's shaking
his head um but um so I'm just trying to
understand so but they're allowing for
um more streamlined testing
and um also they're eliminating
basically you're the first guy you have
kind of the Monopoly on it but it sounds
like from what you're saying if I
understand correctly they're still
licensing though right and so if they're
still licensing if I read the language
in here you're just taking out being
licensed by the FDA as an
interchangeable biological product so
but they're still doing the licensing
it's just that they're altering certain
methodologies and certain prohibition
so I don't understand what this change
of language is doing really and it's
probably just I'm just not putting the
pieces of a puzzle together yet thank
you for that question it's um because
they took that intermediate step of of
these interchangeable we don't know
exactly how they're going to change the
language for the interchangeable so
that's why it's written a way that it is
so that when they determine that
something is equivalent to an
interchangeable um this sort of mushy
language would allow us to recognize
that the FDA has recognized this as
interchange as essentially the same as
interchangeable therefore stay law will
as well thank you you're welcome other
questions representative Woods thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um drilling down a little bit
you may not be able to answer the
question but what are what are the
details about the loosening of the uh
I'll use that term props in properly uh
the change in test thing that's uh
different with the biologic versus a a
new drug that comes out which has really
internationally one of the more rigorous
testing programs and that's to our
detriment in general what is that
difference uh harking back into the
history with Penicillin uh when we found
out that we people were really allergic
to it but it wasn't penicillin it was
the Moy it it was vehicle carry in the
penicillin that was the problem so
there's subtle changes that can be
dramatically even though so what what is
the difference in the testing that uh
and U you may not know the details but
uh I have some concern so I can hit the
surface on this my husband's actually
been involved in biomedical research for
over 30 years and he is intimately
involved in that process for bringing
biologics and biosimilars to Market so
he'll be able to give you more details
than I um he's he's here um I know that
there's also companies that have been
Pioneers in this area who are here as
well so there's going to be a lot of
good scientific knowledge
um but what they're removing was the is
the in-person switching studies because
now they have more and when they're
assessing these um you know you're not
just you're not just looking at a little
stick that says yes it's the same no
it's not it's a lot more highly involved
than that um but other people can speak
to that more and and worldwide have not
been unique Adverse Events from a bio
similar that is different than the
Adverse Events from the reference
molecule so there's risks but they're
the same risks as the original
one other
questions saying no other questions
thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is
Christopher Kent from Amgen
uh good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh my name is Chris Ken I
work as part of uh amen state government
Affairs uh covering New England uh a
little bit of background about uh Amgen
the company that I work for um we are a
biotechnology company backed by four
Decades of experience with the research
development in manufacturing of
Innovator and biosimilar
drugs uh we currently have 11 biosimilar
uh uh products in our portfolio half of
them are marketed and then the other
half are in development
currently uh and we have substantial
ongoing investments in biosimilar
research and development um I just kind
of wanted to talk about um this bill so
last year uh in the uh house Commerce
and consumer affairs committee I sat up
here and opposed the legislation and
currently we still we still oppose the
legislation um for a number of reasons
and it really has to do with patient
safety and uh dosing um that's what it
comes down to in the end if you if you
kind of boil everything down um I I'm
I'm the way that I originally read this
uh the intent was to follow on the bill
last year but it's sounding like um that
this bill uh the intent of it is to uh
have a law in place or a statute in
place um that would follow any type of
actions at the federal level or if FDA
takes it
um I really don't think at this point
the bill is needed uh for a number of
reasons um you know first and foremost I
we believe that the interchangeable
designation is an important one um and
just as a a quick and I'm going to try
to keep this as brief as possible um but
back in June of
2018 um there was a law that passed in
New Hampshire in all 50 states you know
it's it's called the pharmacy
substitution um act and and and the
current law as passed in June of 18 in
New Hampshire and all other all the
other 50 states have it um it permits a
pharmacist to dispense an
interchangeable biosimilar product only
when the brand reference product has
been prescribed um once a substitution
has been made a pharmacist has 3 days to
communicate back to the physician that a
substitution was made in our view um
this law is working very well and we
don't see a need at this time to make
any changes to the law uh including
passing this legislation which you know
in the end I'm not sure the way that we
read it I don't think it really does too
much to be honest um but what this
legislation you know again as the way
that we look at it it would allow a
pharmacist to substitute one designated
interchangeable for another designated
interchangeable but uh I'm learning that
that maybe that you know my reading of
the bill might be incorrect um but again
we we think that the current law is
working well and then there were a
couple of questions I wanted to int also
talk about um you know when uh
representative Weber I think you had
asked about um a patient declining uh a
uh substitution so if you think about it
a lot of these folks that are taking
these biologic medicines are really sick
grievously ill chronically ill folks
that might be in not not might be in the
right mindset um to make a decision
about if a pharmacist is asking them uh
about a substitution also um a lot of
times family members or caregivers will
be there to pick up the prescription as
well and they might not necessarily know
to say something um you know if if we
were to pass something like this in New
Hampshire it would make New Hampshire a
complete outlier this bill has not been
introduced anywhere in the entire
country um I don't know of any any other
uh State that's considering this um and
again this this would make New Hampshire
a complete outlier in in doing this
um another thing that I just kind of
wanted to talk about is is if um uh was
the refuse to yeah um but yeah I mean
that's that's there's the timer I knew
my time was coming up but um you know we
oppose this I don't think that this is
necessarily uh needed to be passed at
this time and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you any
questions wow you covered it
well thank you I don't see any questions
so thank
you also signed up to speak is Jason AIS
from the New Hampshire insurance
department
good morning Mr chair uh for the record
my name is Jason AIS director of Health
Economics New Hampshire insurance
department I also sit on New Hampshire's
prescription drug affordability board
last year the insurance department spoke
on behalf of uh representative Merchants
Bill yes so last year we supported the
passage of this bill when representative
Merchants sponsored it and this year the
insurance department is also in support
of this
bill um I think one thing that
commissioner beton Court feels
importantly about is competition ition
and um providing our citizens with lower
cost alternatives to expensive branded
biologic drugs and we feel that this
bill is a step I'll be an incremental
step um in that direction so we are in
support of this bill and we'll keep my
testimony short so if anybody has any
questions happy to answer them thank you
thank you any
questions seeing no question oh I'm rep
I representative
palaza thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
so from insurance department point of
view like if things if things go
sideways side
sideways if there are some problems with
uh um some
Alternatives and some
concentrations as we heard and if there
will be
some uh I don't know side effects or um
uh damage to patients uh how would it
play with your department will you see
some
effects if you could speak to it yeah so
adverse drug events I think is common
vernacular for side
effects that that's a good question it's
complex I think our Central concern is
the financing of expensive but important
pharmacological Therapies
and we we noted in the 2023 New
Hampshire pdab annual report that um
when you have a a branded biologic
Market that has no competition that
prices are about 230% higher compared to
biologic markets for which biosimilars
have been introduced so there's a we we
noticed an erosion of the Branded
biologic markets once the bio similars
entered we use the the examp Le was
Remicade in
fmab and all three of the bio similars
for Remicade were also in fmab they were
just different isomerized versions of
them if that's the right term so as far
as adverse drug events I think it's very
different compared to the small molecule
and generic
Paradigm uh versus the biologic and
biosimilar they're essentially the same
substances just different um ISO forms
of them so that's the the limits of my
knowledge on that but cost is a big um
cost exerts great harm to people so if
they paying two to three times as much
for the same therapies by definition and
by the construct of the you know the
social ecological model that that also
is an adverse effect on on people's
well-being and that's the lens that we
have in the insurance department who
Insurance finances healthc care delivery
to our society and so that's an
important Central theme of our interest
in this Bill thank you for the question
repres sentive
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um we went
through some of the language of lure FDA
not FDA but um the the gentleman from
amen when he testified he said and I'm
I'm trying to recall everything drinking
a lot that um in
2018 the rules um were that pharmacists
you know if the doctor wrote a script
could prescribe
an alternative or they could on their
own but they had to notifi notify the
position within 3 days so I I'm just
looking at changes I don't see anything
of that in the italicized portion of
this bill so can you speak about the
role of the pharmacist with this bill
the how does this bill deviate from the
2018 law with respect to the role of the
pharmacist it was my understanding from
representative Merchant that this gives
the pharmacist a little bit more
flexibility if the interchangeability
status was was augmented or the barrier
for interchangeability status was
reduced then at the point of sale the
pharmacist would have more flexibility
changing that out for the patient and
that's the limit of my knowledge on that
right so maybe I'll save some followup
for the next speaker then thank you very
much thank you for your question other
questions
seeing none thank you than you so
much also signed up to speak is Dr
Michael
Lon good morning members of the
committee thank you kindly for uh
allowing me to testify this morning my
name is Michael Aon um yes it's Dr Leon
Michael's also uh seven letters I prefer
Michael but uh that be that as it may um
my train as a pharmacologist right here
in New Hampshire um proud to say I did
my training at Dartmouth um I've been
doing biomedical research since the late
80s not quite 40 years but it's getting
Mighty close um I'm hoping in just a few
minutes to be able to communicate a few
things to this committee a what is a
biologic as I know last year the
Commerce Committee deserves a lot of
thanks especially chairman hunt to uh
actually change this position after
looking at the data biologics aren't
that complicated um if if you want to
dig into them um I'd be happy to provide
anyone on this committee a link there's
a two text book they're about this thick
on
biosimilars um you must like a lot of
coffee if you're going to get two those
it's they're they're dense biologics
themselves are quite easy they've been
around a long time um in fact amen who I
used to work for for 13 years one of
their products called nen or Phil gastr
causes the body to make more white blood
cells the specific type of white blood
cell I belong to the American Society of
clinical oncology which called this one
of the biggest breakthroughs of the last
century this biologic basically
transformed the lives of cancer patients
from having to be hospitalized when the
majority of chemotherapies would
suppress a patient's immune system to
the point if you get an infection which
manifest as a fever it's called f
neutropenia it becomes medical
emergency a simple injection in the arm
I hate needles but simple injection in
the arm can be given elsewhere
would help patients produce more of
these nutrifil potentially preventing
infections this was overwhelming um
successful for patients that they were
able to receive their CH chemotherapy
and go home and be with their
family more drugs came along they were
small molecules that got rid of
chemotherapy the nausey and vomiting but
uh needless to say biologics within the
field of oncology have been
transformative it is not their biggest
use if you know anyone who has something
like Ms Crohn's disease disease uh
psoriasis either of the forms of
psoriasis um you may know someone else
was something a nonh or non malignant
hemat hematology uh condition called
immune I'll just call it ITP um people
produce antibodies against their own
platelets there are biologics that treat
these every drug has side effects though
one of the first biologics I grew up in
San Diego place called the scripts
Research Institute it's owned by MD
Anderson out of Texas now was developing
an antibody we to make them in
mice patient with cancer was given a an
antibody from mice absolutely amazing
results on the first infusion
unfortunately the second infusion that
patient died because while the antibody
had worked it had gone in and attacked
cancer cells that patient's body I will
wrap up the patient's body saw the
antibody as a foreign entity and
developed antibodies against it this is
where interchange the the previous
concern about interchangeability
originated from in the
US that was a purely mine uh Mouse
antibody antibodies now are engineered
that they're fully human you can take an
antibody and put it into any person in
this room I hope none of you need them
but if you do you can rest assure they
are now made fully the vast majority are
fully human that your body wouldn't
recognize them our immune systems are
complex biologics are not in a nutshell
aspirin small or small molecules are
made in a test tube if you will they're
they're made by chemicals they are exact
copies of
of the reference product the copies are
exact copies
biosimilars biologic drugs are made in a
living system they're made in cells now
if any of you have ever been to a
brewery or grow hydroponics in big Vats
that's exactly how cells are grown now
um I happy to chat offline anytime about
it I'm a scientist I get excited about
this however even a single comp's
product from today think of a baker if
you bake cookies today and you bake
cookies tomorrow same recipe they're
going to be slightly different in order
for a biologic to be approved the FDA
the company manufacturing it and in the
case of biosimilar the competitors do
pre-clinical testing so they look at it
on a lab bench if you will start
wrapping up please okay yep there there
are at that point differences you look
at animal testing there are not
differences there they can be detected
they wouldn't be considered biosimilar
and then the standard is clinical
testing in clinical testing there cannot
be any distinguishing there they
indistinguishable whether you have a bio
similar or the original biologic and by
indistinguishable I mean both safety and
efficacy if you can't distinguish them
having something that's interchangeable
doing more testing they can't be more
indistinguishable if you can't
distinguish them in the first place okay
thank you so thank you thank you any
questions representative mlan
thank you Mr jar and thank you for
taking my question so again you know I'm
just looking some of the stuff is
italicized but some of the stuff around
the role of the pharmacists it that
doesn't appear like it all is so I just
if you're aware I I want to understand
the role of the pharmacist and how it
changes if this bill
passes absolutely so I think in a in a
nutshell that bill that you're looking
at a biosimilar also has to have the
additional designation which exists only
in the US nowhere else in the world of
being
interchangeable it would remove that
interchangeable and allow a biosimilar
that's not considered interchangeable
it's still
indistinguishable then for a pharmacist
to substitute it but if I can clear for
a pharmacist um I used to work with
representative Merchant clinically we
never chatted politics pharmacists are
underappreciated heroes in our health
care System they not only help with
prescriptions of drugs I was actually
safe from a prescription of penicillin
I'm deadly allergic to it by a
pharmacist they also have to balance
books and if you're pick your favorite
hospital or least favorite if you want
when they choose to have a particular
drug on what they call formulary it's
their their list of drugs that they're
going to keep they may have the
originator molecule they're only
probably going to pick one biosimilar
they're not likely to pick multiple
biosimilars so if someone comes up here
from Florida we're just about to hit
Spring or vice versa someone moves they
move a he healthare system they just
change pharmacies whatever it might be
they may be offered a different
biosimilar and right now this would
allow someone to switch from one bioer
to the other without having to invoke
the originator molecule nor um an
interchangeable follow up yes thank you
now um so so I got that part but if if
this was to pass this bill um as I'm
trying to read it does does that even if
the FDA doesn't change its rules okay
which we've were talking about does that
does the pharmacist still have that kind
of latitude in this bill or no it is
contingent on the FDA rule change I
believe in my reading it is contingent
upon the FDA rule change be right now
they are restricted to interchangeables
only which is an additional designation
that exists only in the US thank you
very much other questions
seeing none thank you thank you
kindly no one else has signed up to
speak on this bill does anyone else wish
to speak on
hb17 if not I'm going to close this
public hearing next public hearing is
scheduled for 1 pm on HCR 7 we're in
recess until then
yeah
e
e e
I made
not okay good all
right
e
for
e e
good afternoon
everyone I am going to start the public
hearing for
hc7 uh representative or chair McDonald
will be here in a few minutes so I'm
just sitting in in his place for a bit
so I'd like to recognize representative
Alexa Simpson the prime sponsor of the
Bill thank you good to see you good to
be here good afternoon everybody
chairwoman chairwoman mour is that how
you say your name merer merer great and
committee
members I'm proud to introduce HCR 7
today which is a simple and
straightforward resolution that allows
our constituents to clearly see where
the New Hampshire house stands on the
right to abortion before four weeks of
pregnancy I've heard from so many of my
constituents that they do not want any
further restrictions on abortion in New
Hampshire and I know many of my
colleagues have heard the same as well
we know that a super majority of granite
Staters want their lawmakers to take
proactive action on abortion rights in
New Hampshire New Hampshire is the only
state in New England that doesn't have
the right to abortion clearly spelled
out in their state law or our state
constitution this lack of clarity is
confusing for voters and it's our job as
lawmakers to be clear what HCR 7 does is
clearly show our constituents that our
house position on abortion that an
individual's ability to access abortion
before 20 weeks of pregnancy shall not
be denied or infringed upon by the
government we saw how important abortion
was in the 2024 election legislators
lawmakers so many of us running for
office promised on the campaign Trail to
not further restrict abortion in New
Hampshire now it's time to put our words
into action New Hampshire for so long
has had a long proud bipartisan
tradition of supporting Reproductive
Rights by voting against harmful
legislation but it's not enough to vote
against abortion restrictions and bans
our constituents would like us to vote
proactively to support access to
abortion it's important we as an elected
body need to show Granite Staters our
values our priorities and our firm and
clear position and we can do that by
passing HCR
7 so I respectfully urge you all on the
committee and our colleagues to vote
ought to pass on HCR 7 uh a commitment
and an action to not further restrict
abortion rights in New
Hampshire and now I'll take any
questions that you all have thank you
representative any questions from the
committee yes representative L Montaine
thank you for taking my question um do
you know of other states outside of New
England that have passed such
resolutions um I don't I mostly looked
at New England where um the right to
abortion up to 24 weeks is codified
instate law so there wouldn't um
necessarily be a need for a resolution
like
this
okay representative paaz off
thank you Madame chair and thank you for
taking my
question so this bill uh says uh
that uh PRI prior to 24 weeks uh
gestation um so my question would
be how you define a comprehensive
uh reproductive Health
Care uh because sometimes uh abortion is
made based on uh threat
to uh women's uh health and sometimes uh
it could be more of a choice
so uh would you define
so from my perspective and the folks
that I'm representing it's really
important that decisions about health
care reproductive healthare and
otherwise are made between doctors and
women so doctors and the person who's
pregnant um so I
would I would leave those decisions up
to healthc care
providers representative
mlan thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question so we we have
some some varying statutes that are
specific with respect to dates so the
fetal Life protection act it it
references 24 weeks and and it has to
reference a specific time because
obviously you want to give people
Clarity right and the same thing we have
with our our our female fetal homicide
law which was used the first time last
year which basically sets it at 20 weeks
and you want to be very clear you know
so if if in in the case of of the the
criminal action last year the woman was
37 and the fetus was over 20 weeks and
so the the person was charged with two
murders as opposed to one but had the
fetus just been 18 weeks they would have
just been charged with the one murder so
when it comes to the statutes we have
this specificity to be as clear as
possible but this is a resolution and so
I'm just wondering um your thought proc
process you know rather than like say at
at a point of viability or something
like that you're coming in with a with a
hard number 24 weeks and what was your
thinking behind uh you know that number
specifically because it may evolve so
just if you could kind
of if you could let me know what your
thinking was towards the 24-week number
sure so the um law that's on the books
the fetal Life protection act is um up
until 20 4 weeks so I use that as the
resolution
yeah follow up M follow up so just
basically that's our status quo and I
just want to kind of hold the line on
that
basically right now in the law that is
what is in the fetal Life protection act
and this resolution is attending to
everything before what's in the law
right now so you're so you're just
trying to preserve of that status quo in
the resolution
basically I'm trying to make a statement
and have the house make a statement that
we affirmatively support Reproductive
Rights and and Health Care up until 24
weeks thank
you representative Maser thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so you just said right now you're in
support of the 24 weeks would you be
support of a resolution like that if um
for abortion up until
birth I think that's an inflammatory
statement that's not an actual thing
that happens in reproductive health care
it's not um it's not what we're talking
about we're talking about reproductive
health care and
abortion at the time of birth is not a
health care a thing that happens in
healthare so I'm not going to talk about
that a quick followup follow quick
clarification I said up until
birth not right and I am saying that
abortion up until birth does not happen
I think it might be helpful for you to
ask that question of a provider of
Health Care who may be testifying after
me but um that's not something I'm going
to talk
about other
questions I'm seeing no other questions
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is
representative Mary hackin Phillips one
of the
co-sponsors thank you Mr chair members
of the health and human services and
elderly Affairs committee for the record
I'm representative Mary hecken Phillips
serving Handover and lime from the
Grafton 12 seat and I'm here today as a
co-sponsor and support of HCR
7 so many if not most of the States
practicing OBGYNs live in or practice
adjacent to my
district um um more so than any other
District in the state so um you may not
be familiar but lebanon's Dartmouth
Hitchcock uh Medical Center is a mere
two miles from my home so I'm here to
speak on behalf of New Hampshire's
practicing OBG who could not be here
today because they're at work um on why
abortion is a critical component of
comprehensive Healthcare in our state so
I'm going to share two academic studies
with you and then an anecdote from one
of those Physicians for your
consideration so first the Journal of
American medical excuse me the Journal
of American Medical Association or
jamama uh has a study published in
February of 2024 that reports a
statistically significant decline in
medical residency applications were
found in states with abortion banss
fewer applications for Residency program
can lead to a decline in the quality and
quantity of young medical residents at
the beginning of their Career Training
in a program that will ultimately feed
those residents into the hospital
systems as attending physicians for all
all OBGYN practice areas yes so that
means fewer abortions in New Hampshire
also means fewer OBGYN procedures for
preventative care and reproductive Care
by fewer of the best
physicians second the Journal of
American Medical Association study
published in January of
2024 reports that OBGYNs practicing an
abortion ban States perceived impacts
that
include distress and delaying essential
patient care fears of legal
ramifications mental health effects and
planned or actual attrition so that's
right abortion bans cause New
Hampshire's existing OBG to suffer while
they work to deliver patient care
to fear fines imprisonment and loss of
lure and retaliation for delivering care
to experience mental health challenges
as a result and then to become more
likely to leave their states of practice
for states without the abortion banss so
yes fewer abortions mean fewer existing
OBG GYN care um practicing Physicians
for all grandit
Staters so to sum up these two studies
findings are directly reflected here in
New Hampshire
current law limiting one subset of
procedures hurts Granite Staters chances
of receiving regular preventative
maintenance and maintenance care for
their reproductive health and so we're
damaging the sustainability of our
existing and future OBGYN care here in
the granite
state third I'm here to relay an
important constituent story for your
consideration an OBG physician who's a
professor at the G Gil school of
medicine and um the darmouth area who is
also licensed to practice here in New
Hampshire and Vermont reports that the
legislative limits on this Medical
Practice in New Hampshire are pushing
him to stop offering his Provider
Services in New Hampshire and move his
clinical practice exclusively to Vermont
he feels that the laws regulating
abortion care in New Hampshire are an
unfair intrusion on his medical
decision-making which follow national
standards of care and are also an unfair
judgment upon his medical expertise he
can EAS move his practice to an
environment more supportive of his
practice without suffering repercussions
and there is nothing holding him back
other than recognizing that New
Hampshire would be become more of a
reproductive Healthcare desert than it
already is if you could start wrapping
up please y so this resolution if passed
would provide this doctor and the rest
of the state's OBGYN as a signal of
support that New Hampshire trusts its
OBGYN Physicians and values their
difficult
work prior um prior to the 24-week band
so protecting this vital access to
abortion care is just one important part
of this clinical work and passing this
resolution will
assure more doctors like him that New
Hampshire is serious about giving
providers all the tools they need to be
the to provide the best care for their
patients and their patients families so
it's an important moral Victory I really
think you should consider so um for
these reasons Mr chair and members of
the committee I urge you to support this
resolution and with that I thank you for
your attention I would be happy to
answer any questions you might have
thank you representative palaz off thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so you you mentioned
significant decline uh in some numbers
uh is related to OBG YN and some
enrollments could you put some number or
in terms of percentage is it like 1%
decline like how much I'd be happy to
forward you the study after
this other
questions representative mlan thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so I mean obviously um abortion
is is is a very you know divisive issue
and people come down on multiple sides
of it um and and so it it can be a
difficult discussion but you talked
about um the fact that since uh our
existing went into effect we've seen um
a loss of service and you you gave the
specific example of a of a physician who
who moved his practice to to Vermont
which is a a tangible effect so you know
in light of that
um what what is your objective I mean
you you could go back and you could
revisit the statute or you could look
like some other states have done at a
constitutional amendment instead you're
choosing the path of this
resolution um and I'm I which I I don't
really think has all that much teeth to
it and so what are you seeing that the
gain is going to be from this I'm just
trying to
understand thank you for the question
representative so as I was finishing up
my remarks I talked about the important
signal it would send to doctors who
practice in this field that New
Hampshire's legislators actually care
about people and they put people over
politics U recogn ing that this simple
subset procedure of an overall practice
is being limited for more or less
arbitrary you know purposes it's um you
know a policy decision um but if you
were to support the resolution you would
let them know that the rest of their
practice is supported and that their
jobs and their hard work their difficult
decision-making prior to 24 weeks is
valued because we understand that this
subset procedure for the overall
practice is required prior to 20 4 weeks
in many cases to in order to keep the
regular reproductive healthare of our
Granite State reproductive folks you
know in a healthy position so um I do
not believe that they are separated I
think that these two things can live in
the same space and coexist in in a
meaningful way um just because we have
something after 24 weeks doesn't mean
that we can't affirm what they're doing
prior to 24 weeks so um I think that
signal is important for the physician
who are working here to address almost
every single one of our families has a
female who has been or will be or could
become pregnant so um the support that
you could show with this resolution um
would be very powerful for their morale
um considering the previous attacks that
they've had on their profession but more
than that I think that the signal would
also be sent to every um patient patient
family member or simply persons who love
a patient who could become pregnant by
showing them that Healthcare is we
understand Healthcare is complex it's
personal and it's private prior to 24
weeks and so that's the meaning of our
resolution today
follow thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so and and I
understand you know your comments about
uh the the moral position that it Stakes
out um in your conversation uh with the
positions that that you're representing
um have any of them commented to you
including perhaps this position that's
moving to Vermont where they said if
this was to pass even though this is
something that you know structurally has
no teeth it would be enough for us to
consider moving
back um well I can't put words into the
person's mouth no but I have had several
conversations with practicing physicians
in the state who believe this affir like
this resolution or affirmative support
of their work prior to 24 weeks is
critical for what they do in the state
not only because it would provide some
legislative intent for you know in terms
of how the legislature feels prior to 24
weeks but also because it would show you
know that professional support I was
just speaking with you about the
morale thank you representative Markel
did you have your hand up then
representative thank you for taking my
call my question um so ma'am earlier we
heard it discussed that there's no
abortion basically if I heard it
correctly and perhaps you can clarify
this for me uh that there's no
protections for abortion in New
Hampshire however could you please
comment on RSA 3
2944 which addresses the issue that uh
that basically says no abortion will be
performed after 24 weeks unless there is
a medical emergency doesn't isn't that
enough for you to satisfy this uh this
particular call and satisfy the um
problems that you say some of the OBGYNs
are having uh thank you for the question
um to respond I would say um the
question addressed to the earlier Prime
sponsor was outside the scope of this
resolution okay um so I would decline to
comment based on that it's not really
the resolution we're discuss discussing
here today um I just don't think that's
relevant to the discussion we're trying
to hold so I'm sorry I can't comment
okay thank you representative
palaza thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking another question from me so uh uh
in the bill title and in the bill you
talk about cre iCal component so how do
you define a critical component is it
does it mean that it is equal in
importance to other components or are
you saying that it's more important than
some other uh components of
healthcare thank you for the question um
no if you'll go back to refer to my
previous statements I mentioned that
abortion care is one subset of the tools
in the practice area that
OBG are responsible for in their sco
practice so um I don't believe one is
more important than the other I think
that's the that's the idea of the
resolution is to show that each subset
of the practice area is part of the
comprehensive reproductive health care
that all Granite Staters
deserve other questions representative
McGrath thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my questions I'm
I'm still confused by the doctor who's
moving to Vermont what
are if if it's because of our
abortion after 24 weeks what is
Vermont's
law uh I am not um fully studied on the
like expanded nature of the Vermont law
but my understanding is that they do
have a constitutional amendment
affirming the right to abortion in
Vermont so they have um spoken in their
law where where our law is silent so
they have actually made affirmative
Protections in their law through a
constitutional amendment our state has
no affirmative Protections in law prior
to 24
weeks representative CLE ring I iose
just to end the comment I suppose the
doctor realizes that his practice he's
not under criminal threat for his full
scope of practice in the state of
Vermont where he is under criminal
threat and civil Li ility here in the
state of New Hampshire so his benefit to
moving his practice in Vermont for his
professional lure purposes is a a lower
risk practice field in Vermont than it
is here in New
Hampshire representative custle wi thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so I heard you mention about
the doctors you're speaking for today um
is there in your study anything that
shows the pregnancy rate decreasing in
New Hampshire um because I would be
concerned that that would be one of the
reasons that the doctors would leave uh
thank you for the question I will make
sure to forward both of the studies to
the committee so that they can look this
is a national peer-reviewed study since
the fall um Ro versus Wade and the dobs
decision so um it it just measured the
uh I think 11 states that reversed um
the abortion rights since that happened
so I will be sure to pass along both
studies to the committee so you can
fully inform yourself of the um the
Journal of American Medical Association
uh published studies from 2024 so that's
like a short window of time to turn
around the the end of do you know the
do's decision and these um these studies
but you know that information is limited
and I don't think it's siloed to which
states other than the ones that have
passed
bans other
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Janet Lucas from I
committee
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record I am Janet
Lucas and I represent Grafton County
district
7 which is Campton I testify today as an
obst nurition gynecologist with 37 years
practice and instruction experience in a
Catholic Health Care system during my
career I served on numerous Hospital
committees including the Ethics
Committee and his Department
chairperson there are many
life-threatening complications of
pregnancy that if allowed to continue
would result in death severe disability
or the irreversible loss of the
expectant mother's future
fertility these include placental and
fetal
abnormalities that cause maternal heart
failure in the early second
trimester pre-existing maternal
conditions such as certain congenital
heart diseases for example Eisen manger
syndrome pulmonary
hypertension kidney disorders cancers
ectopic pregnancies a history of
postpartum psychosis
alcohol abuse and IV drug use resulting
in bacterial
endocarditis I encountered all of these
and other high-risk pregnancies when the
balance of maternal and Fetal
well-being challenged all caregivers
involved to render the best care based
on the most current information and
Technology
available when the patient was not for
my practice I was still often involved
in the decision-making process process
as head of the department and adviser to
the hospital CEO who at the time
happened to be a
nun there were times when the only
option to save the mother's life was to
medically end her pregnancy as
heartbreaking as that decision was for
me personally I never believed we had
made the wrong
choice and it was an informed Choice
made without the unnecessary pressure of
policies originating from outside of the
medical
field a study by the Tain University
School of Public Health found that
states with more abortion restrictions
had a 7% increase in total mat maternal
mortality compared to states with few or
no abortion restrictions to quote the
lead author of the study it is
critically important that state level
policies related to women's access to
comprehensive reproductive care services
including abortion are evidence-based
and guided by the primary goal of
improving Women's Health and reducing
maternal
mortality the numbers are not in dispute
in states with strict abortion bans
women are dying at accelerating rates
states with abortion bans or
restrictions have adverse outcomes
including declining enrollment in their
OBGYN residencies departure of trained
Specialists to practice in other less
restrictive States just finishing up
maternity care deserts and elevated
death rates for women of reproductive
age it's well known that women make the
health care decisions in their families
if they have a good experience in
obstetric and gynecologic care they are
likely to refer their family members for
other kinds of care to the same facility
women also influence decisions on where
their families will live based on
quality of Health Care education and
other factors New Hampshire should be a
welcoming state for all families who
happen to have female members I ask you
to support HCR 7 thank you thank you be
happy to take any questions thank you
any questions uh representative um
lontine and then representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question just so I
understand correctly you're working
mainly for a Catholic um Health
Service and I imagine that they probably
had uh policies that not did not allow
elective
abortion but in the case of a medical
emergency um there was no prohibition to
doing what you had to do as the provider
that's correct
representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and and thank
you for taking my question and thank you
for sharing your insights as well um so
um already in Statute in New Hampshire
is the statutory guarantee of
unrestricted access to abortion through
24 weeks this resolution basically
preserves that it says yeah we're going
to 24 weeks but you know if you look at
the last matter of protection being
offered the statutory protections far
outweigh any protections that may be
gained from a resolution and so when I I
heard the earlier testimony um about
someone who had left to go to Vermont
the reason that they were leaving to go
to Vermont was because in Vermont it was
higher up on the ladder still in that it
was a constitutional protection and so I
guess what I'm still trying to
understand is having already achieved
the statutory protection which is higher
than the resolution I'm still trying to
understand what it is that you're trying
to achieve with this I I don't know that
it's going to be able to you know bring
back um the the Physicians and the
Obstetricians because the the the the
life- saving care where you had to
basically make the decision to save the
life of the mother um that's all
protected within the existing statute so
I guess what I'm trying to ask is where
does the resolution take you because
it's it's it doesn't even give you that
same level that a statute does thank you
I I think I'm looking at this more as a
statement of
reassurance
to Future Physicians who are considering
practicing here I have
um after 37 years um of of instruction I
have literally hundreds of graduates uh
of The Residency program where I was a
clinical
instructor and I know that because I'm
in touch with quite a few of them that
many of them have made a decision to
leave
States uh who have enacted stricter
abortion
uh
restrictions and they are also leaving
states where they
are not aware of a firm commitment to
protecting re women's Reproductive
Rights because they're concerned about
the future so I think that this
resonates with me because I'm hearing
about those decisions and I'm concerned
about what could happen in New
Hampshire follow up and and so again
with with the extensive conversations
that you have with these folks
um understanding that the law is already
there
um have you had discussions with them
about this resolution and you know is it
a game Cher in any way for them would it
move the needle for them or you know I'm
just trying to I'm just trying to
understand the substantive impact that
this would have well for the former
residents who
are considering changing location and
they're if they look at the New England
states I know that they're not looking
at New
Hampshire for that reason
yeah representative
Weber thank you Mr chair and before I
ask my question I am a co-sponsor of
this bill but it is my understanding
that I am allowed to ask a question if
I'm not testifying that that is correct
okay thank you uh so to
clarify am I correct that the intent
here let let me start at a different
from the other end isn't it true that
the criminal statute is a Prohibition
that starts at 24 weeks and goes
forward and whatever concerns I have
about the way that's written for people
Beyond 24 weeks is irrelevant to this
particular piece of legislation but but
what this legislation does is speak
affirmatively to the intent of the
legislature
about abortion prior to 24 weeks which
is a subject on which our current law is
silent and that's the difference correct
thank you I uh representative palaza
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so I wonder about
what effects this bill uh we'll have on
New Hampshire so uh as far as I heard
from other sponsors uh of this build
testifying here today that they look to
attract and retain more Specialists
performing abortions to New Hampshire so
it's probably safe to say that there
will be more abortions performed in New
Hampshire as a effect uh if this
resolution to pass uh so can we say that
this this will have effect of New
Hampshire having a fewer kids
um I think I disagree with the premise
of your question in that I don't believe
this would
attract um or result in more abortions
being performed I think it
would helped
to make sure that we had accessible and
available reproductive Health Care to
all women and that abortion is such a
small part of that but when an OBGYN
makes a decision on where to practice um
that includes all of the other kinds of
care that's
provided other
questions I'm seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is bmer
representative Kurt walper
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Kurt
welper I live in
straford uh I'm chairman of New
Hampshire rights life and I here in
radical opposition to this
resolution um my written testimony which
I have already submitted
online talks about the legal history and
the foundational
importance of protecting life in our
country whether it's the Declaration of
Independence the constitution of the
State of New Hampshire or the Federal
Constitution all of
those talk about the
importance of enjoying and Andor
defending life
everyone not taking
life so this has abortion is a cancer in
our
society and has corrupted that uh
virtually every area it touches the law
medicine and since we're talking about a
healthc care
reproductive Health Care we'll talk
about
medicine prior to the abortion regime in
our
country the hypocritic oath for
centuries
eons prohibited anything that would even
assist
in The Taking of the life of the
pre-born it's only in the
wake of the
abortion regime in our
country that the hypocritic C was
changed to remove that
prohibition and today's
OBGYN many many of them have no sense
that life itself
is worth
preserving
no if you call killing health care you
can go to assisted death why not we
heard this over and over in the
testimony on that bill this year and
previously because medicine now includes
killing no it doesn't health care is
about healing and about extending
life so all of these things that you
hear
and one of the things uh representative
palazov I think asked the important
question would you define reproductive
healthc care nobody
will because it well no no nobody
will so we shouldn't absolutely
absolutely should be totally opposed to
any um
support for abortion even the Supreme
Court of the United States when it did
Ro versus Wade said if we knew that the
object of that
abortion was a human
being abortion would already be
unconstitutional by the 14th
Amendment this is
intolerable and useless on top of it and
I will answer any questions thank you
any questions representative mlan and
then representative
palazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um I'm we
going to kind of flip it a little bit
and kind of ask you the same question
that I were asking some of the the
previous folks who testified you know on
the other side of the bill um the way I
see the hierarchy of this I I I see we
have the fet of Life protection act it
in my opinion codifies that you have
access for 24 weeks um
so and and they've made their position
as to how it would you know benefit but
from your position um
tangibly within the pro-life Community
what impact is this going to have
because it has no teeth so where where
do you see this having impact how do you
see this having impact uh the Journey of
a Thousand Miles begins with the first
step the first step in the case of again
abolishing or all of our abortion laws
which has happened once before in our
state's history
is to establish that well you know
abortion is a good thing and the house
should be on record as supporting it and
that's what's this about it is not about
reproductive health care it's about
killing
babies and getting the house on record
because if you say if you approve that
phrase reproductive Health Care without
the
definition then it absolutely includes
the killing of these pre-born children
and we know that over 60
million
healthy babies have been taken by
abortion for no other reason
than and and it it like I said it has
corrupted the the medical industry to
the point where now abortion is the
first answer if you get a a take a a
prenatal diagnosis J Test it says you
have markers for uh um fatal
anomalies that could turn out to be
serious the first thing they answer they
they represent they recommend is
abortion and the testimony of
women Legions of women who were
pressured to
aborting for these kinds of reasons did
and did not is
enormous it's just the corruption of
abortion so follow no thank you
representative palazov thank you Mr J
thank you for taking my
question uh
so uh in terms of
uh uh so you made a good point about uh
medical profession and
Oban profession changing its
philosophy but we have to deal with OBG
YN uh the way they are today and uh
supporters of this bill who spoke before
you if I understood correctly they say
that without this
resolution we we are going to scare some
of
OBGYN professionals and they will leave
New Hampshire move to Vermont or
otherwise and uh pregnant women will be
left with no support at all in New
Hampshire so do you share any of those
concerns well yes and
no I mean I believe women should have
good health care and pregnant women and
their
babies should have good health
care but that does not include killing
the
baby because that's not protecting the
woman's Health in way over 90% of all
cases and it's not protecting the baby's
Health in any
case
so I guess that's the my answer to your
question other questions representative
Woods thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um is there any
circumstances that you can Envision or
it would be a benefit for a patient to
undergo an abort
so I got two answers to
that and again it's yes and no but the
yes and no in this case depend on what
you mean by
abortion all the all the abortion laws
of which I
aware allow for
the good medical treatment of the
mother
and for the treatment of that
mother to be a cause of death of the
baby but the legal definition of
abortion is the intentional killing of
the innocent child the intentional
killing right if you terminate the
pregnancy simply to get rid of the
child then that's not that's an illegal
abortion that's punishable as a crime in
our in our
state and many others as it should
be but if the mother has an ailment an
illness an emergency situation that's
threatening her
life than trying to protect her
life is a um ethical
choice that has to be made by the
medical professionals and as far as I
know even states with abortion banss
still allow for that kind of treatment
when necessary
other
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Lacy
ferenbach all right hello my name is
Lacy I am a New Hampshire born and
raised I come from Auburn and I'm here
to speak today about keeping abortions
safe and legal in New Hampshire and I
think the person who just spoke before
me actually did an excellent job of
explaining to exactly why we need this
so as you can see we have so many people
who really don't understand a lot about
women's rights about women's health
about what abortion is and how it works
and why people are getting it and it's
not really impacting them it's a
hypothetical that they don't like
meanwhile while people like me and my
friends who are married and trying to
have children have all decided to
stop because they are so afraid of what
will happen if they do become pregnant
in the next few months and then
everything that's currently happening in
the current president's Administration
happens New Hampshire residents are
terrified right now to get pregnant and
have children the ones who actually want
to which means that families are going
to be struggling to have these children
while people who are unable to handle
children let alone themselves are going
to be forced to carry these kids to term
if we get rid of abortion now I could
sit here and say yeah we do have
something already saying that it is
protected but we also have people like
Chris anunu who run on a platform of
protecting abortion and health rights
and then taking it away as soon as
they're voted in um and so we need more
protections to guarantee that you guys
aren't going to do that and that you
aren't going to be ripping away things
that we already agreed on once but then
another committee disagreed
to that's what I have to
say any
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Dr
Young I believe New Hampshire Medical
Society perhaps or
good afternoon and thank you for this
opportunity my name is Dr o
young I'm a retired obci
gynecologist and I'm before you uh today
to speak in support of HC or
7 I practiced uh
and conquered for almost 40 years I'm a
past president of the New Hampshire
Medical
Society and I served on the general
Council representing all the
Obstetricians in the state of New
Hampshire for 20
years also I taught Dartmouth medical
students they would come to conquer for
their third year clerkship in
OBGYN and they're still coming to
conquer
when I was a third-year obgy and
clerkship medical student at St Paul
Ramsey Hospital in St Paul Minnesota we
admitted a young woman with severe
hypotension fever and chills and vaginal
bleeding clearly she was in septic shock
and confessed to having had an illegal
abortion the week
before we gave her IV fluids and the
best antibiotics we had at the time and
then took her to the operating room to
remove her perforated infected
[Music]
uterus our patient was an honor
student and captain of her high school
basketball
team I asked her if she had informed her
parents that she was pregnant and she
confided that her father was responsible
for her pregnancy
and she'd rather die than tell her mom
that she was
pregnant unfortunately she did die a few
days
later I would tell my medical students
this story as part of a history of
medicine history of our Oban specialty I
explained that they would likely never
see a young woman with a septic abortion
because of Ro
vade in 1973
making certain that
women were
free to have access to Legal safe
terminations of
pregnancy unlike my older Partners who
trained in New York City during the
1950s they would never have to watch
women die of illegal unsterile abortions
leaving often orphans at home I
emphasize that our country was not
contributing to the estimated
22 million unsafe abortions
annually in countries where there was
limited access to Safe abortion
resulting in tens of thousands of deaths
and
disabilities little did I know that
politics would creep into the US Supreme
Court pick it stop v Wade please stop
wrapping would be reversed almost done
abortion is not about politics it's
about safe Health Care for Women for
women the decision to terminate a
pregnancy is difficult and deeply
personal a matter that should only be
decided in private between a physician
or caregiver and the woman lawmakers who
know nothing about practicing medicine
or caring for
women should be making this decision for
her legislators who know nothing about a
woman situation in her life should never
have a voice in her
medical decisions when especially when
it comes to pregnancy providing private
safe Health Care to women gives them
control over their bodies and freedom to
make this world a better
place thank you any
questions saying none thank you
also signed up to speak is Danielle
janki I'm not sure I'm pronouncing your
last name
correctly you're not but it's okay most
people don't it's yonke it's German I'm
sorry okay no
problem thank you very much for your
time
um my name is Daniel Yoni and I am a new
resident of New Hampshire I a first year
law school student I'll will speak
quickly as I have a criminal law quiz at
2:45 um I am originally from Michigan
where our governor and legislature
catified abortion into our constitution
in response to the Dos
decision as a young educated woman who
hopes to have a family one day it is a
priority for me to live in a state that
has access to abortion for whatever
reason that may arise Pew research
studies in 2024 on a public opinion
about abortion has two of Americans and
2third of women believing in access to
abortion I hope that the legislature and
Governor can take this initial step in
this resolution to affirm the access to
reproductive Health Care to ensure the
health safety and prosperity of women in
New Hampshire for years to come thank
you very much for your time and
consideration uh I won't be taking any
further questions at this time great
thank
you also signed up to speak is Greg cono
I believe it
is again I don't know if I'm pronouncing
that name correctly I apologize if I'm
not you've asked for three to five
minutes sir if you could keep it closer
to three I appreciate
it yeah that won't be a problem um this
is my first time testifying or having
anything to do with the government
besides voting so I'm nervous
and we have a question I'll keep it as
short as possible so I don't screw up
and I forgot my stuff on the kitchen
counter your last name k
yes my name is Greg kungle okay I am uh
I head up abolish abortion New Hampshire
and I'm here to oppose HR HCR 7 um I am
coming from an abolitionist uh
standpoint where um what we want to do
is we are committed to the uh total
equivocal and un and immediate abolition
of abortion in the state of New Hamshire
and so I've been listening a little bit
to this and
you know it's just kind of I I I'm a
little bit confused because well first
of all we're talking we're talking about
uh abortion and Health Care like there's
one person involved but there are two
we're talking about a pregnant woman and
when we Define pregnancy I looked it up
on on the way in Miriam Webster defines
pregnancy is of a
woman having the condition of carrying
an unborn Offspring so there's a second
person involved in this and and we're
just totally ignoring that person's
standpoint
so I think that's important to consider
and not lose sight of and I think it's
IM immoral to purposely lose sight of it
so we're talking about abortion
Healthcare and abortion like it's the
same thing but it's not it's two
separate things there's abortion and
there's Health Care they are not the
same and all this conflating all this
all this stuff really has no bear
bearing here healthc care is it's two
words put together Health and Care
it's talking about saving lives and
making them well abortion kills a human
being Health Care saves there is no
version of Health Care that kills a
human
being and if you think
that's uh untrue of if you think if
anybody thinks it's uh Not a Human Being
we're talking about inside the womb then
go ahead and take an abortion pill and
give it to a pregnant mother who wants
to have that child and find out how
quickly you are charged with
homicide because if if we're talking
about we're only talking about the
mothers who don't want their children uh
here and the mothers that want their
children it's it's homicide if if you go
and mess with
that so what what is abortion then
abortion is defined as the ending of of
a pregnancy the early ending of a
pregnancy that does not result in a live
birth so by by definition a pregnant is
a human being pregnant pregnancy
involves a second human being in the
womb and by definition abortion kills
that's not
Healthcare so I from a abolished
abortion totally oppose that and
furthermore I think that to get right
with this to get right with this issue
it's not confusing we've made it
confusing by 15 we bills 24 we bills
where it's wrong to kill babies here but
it's okay to kill babies there take our
state's existing murder laws and apply
them to when life begins at conception
which is fertilization thanks thank you
any
questions seeing done okay thank you
sir also signed up to speak is Nancy
Brennan
good afternoon thank you for taking my
testimony Nancy Brennan I'm from we and
I would like to read testimony from a
friend who couldn't be here I told him I
would read his testimony and pass it out
he is in support of
hc7 our state has arguably the strongest
tradition of respect for personal
individual privacy of any state when I
served in the general court many years
ago with only a small handful of
exceptions every member of this body
upheld the principle as it applied to
Reproductive Rights in general and to
the right to choose abortion in
particular particular I urge all members
of this committee to recognize that any
failure to strongly support All rights
to personal individual privacy will lead
to an erosion of New Hampshire's privacy
rights more broadly granted Staters must
proudly stand up for the rights of all
even those with whom we may strongly
disagree if we fail at that ultimately
every Citizen's Freedom will be at risk
this is a statement from Rob blakney
here in conquer and I will give you
those I would just like to add that as a
76y old woman who lived through times
before row I knew of people who went
through
things I don't know of anybody that died
my mother did but there were people my
age who could never have children and
after they had abortions that were
unsafe and I will
say I am in favor of this I wish it was
going to be enshrined in our
constitution there will always be
abortions and if we pass bills to stop
abortion then women of privilege will
still be able to get the
and the people who will suffer will be
the people who can handle it the least
thank
you thank you any
questions thank
you also signed up to speak is best sker
hi hi my name is Beth scare and I'm a
grandmother from Nashua I am here today
to speak in opposition to
hc7 um I'll read a quote from Federica
Matthew Matthews Green which I'll send
to you later the problem is that it's a
baby winds up in deadlock with it's a
woman's right the two statements do not
refute each other so no resolution is
possible what's more they continue a
pernicious fallacy that dead that deadly
conflict between women and children is a
normal State of
Affairs in no sane country are women and
their own children assumed to be mortal
enemies any culture that does so is
slowly committing
suicide when we accept as normal The
Ripping of a child from her mother's
womb
we violate something disturbingly close
to the heart of the human story in the
land where women kill their unborn
children every lesser love grows
frail please vote itl on
hc7 thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak uh is
Claire and
tum
taani from reproductive Equity
now Tani is that correct tone thank okay
good afternoon thank you chairman and
members of the House house Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee
uh for the record my name is CLA tone
and I'm here on behalf of reproductive
Equity now to speak in support of HCR 7
reproductive Equity now works uh across
New England to make Equitable access to
the full spectrum of reproductive
Healthcare reality for our PE all people
um as we've discussed uh this afternoon
as New Hampshire is the only state in
New England without affirmative legal
protections for abortion either in its
statute or in its Constitution Granite
Staters are not impervious or immune to
the threats to abortion care that we are
seeing from States across the country
and to the threats that we expect to see
coming from the national level these
threats and the patch work of uh laws
governing access to abortion care
Nationwide results in chaos in confusion
and harm for real people in real
communities including your constituents
who need access to basic and Essential
Health Care that gives them the freedom
to make their own decisions and to fully
control their bodies lives and Futures
this is why we are urging you today to
act favorably on HCR 7 a resolution that
will clearly and simply communicate to
residents of New Hampshire that abortion
is Healthcare that abortion is a
critical component of comprehensive
reproductive healthare and that it is
the policy position of this body that an
individual's right to terminate their
own pregnancy prior to 24 weeks and
control their own future will not be
denied across the country as I've noted
chaos and confusion abounds with regard
to understanding the legality and
accessibility of abortion care um
polling for example shows that over half
of All American women are unsure about
the legality of medication abortion in
their state HCR 7 offers an opportunity
to combat this
misinformation um and confusion and to
cut through the noise and help Granite
Staters in particular cut through the
noise with a simple message that
abortion as I've said is a critical
component of reproductive health care
and that our state government will not
infringe upon or deny this right to care
Granite Staters overwhelmingly support
reproductive freedom and believe that
there should be a right to abortion in
every state across the country and so
after dos handed the fight for abortion
access back to state governments HCR 7
is New Hampshire's opportunity this
session to take this positive action
affirming reproductive Freedom that
Granite Staters are looking for um I'll
finally close with with uh with noting
that advancing hr7 aligns very closely
with New Hampshire's very long-standing
history and Legacy of affirming personal
freedoms and we urge you to support the
resolution thank you so much thank you
any
questions saying none thank you
thanks also signed up to speak is Liz
Canada from Planned Parenthood New
Hampshire action fund
good afternoon good afternoon thank you
honorable members of the House Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs
committee uh my name is Liz Canada I'm
the advocacy director for Planned
Parenthood of Northern New England and
Planned Parenthood New Hampshire action
fund and we are in strong support of HCR
7 when the US Supreme Court overturned
roie Wade in June of
2022 they took away the federal right to
abortion and since then as of today 19
states have banned abortion or severely
restricted abortion and that number has
changed because of court cases and
because some states have amended their
constitutions but the bottom line is
that other states have taken action to
further restrict abortion New Hampshire
as we just heard as well New Hampshire
is the only state in New England that
doesn't have any state law or uh state
constitution protections explicitly
listed and I heard representative marle
you mentioned earlier the statute about
um after 24 weeks and just want to
clarify that part of that same law is
that there is no I believe it's 329
colon 49 there is no right to abortion
it it says that a few lines later and so
we want to make sure that we are clear
that in New Hampshire we don't have
protections we don't have any um
statutory
guarantees in the
fall there was a survey that went out
that show showed
64% of granite Staters want their state
lawmakers to take positive proactive
action on abortion rights and so HCR 7
before you this resolution does just
that it shows that there is uh the
position of the chamber that you will
not further restrict abortion from what
is already on the
books voting against harmful legislation
um I believe it was two weeks ago uh the
house voted to withdraw the 15we
abortion ban which was which was great
we're in strong support of that action
as well but voting against harmful bills
is one step in that process the other is
taking a positive action and that's what
this resolution does it simply shows
constituents that you will not further
restrict abortion from what's already
there and that's why the 24 weeks is in
the resolution I believe um and it is a
clear position that only you as
lawmakers can take there were a lot of
elected officials who ran uh and talked
in their campaigns about not wanting to
further restrict abortion and that's
what this resolution says it allows you
to take that action and show that
commitment explicitly through that vote
so we would urge you to vote ought to
pass on HCR 7 thank you thank you any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so much
also signed up to speak is stepen
SK good afternoon chairman mcdal and
distinguished members of the
committee I urge you to vote against
this res this
resolution I believe believe in
protecting human life since birth having
said that I understand that this does
affect autonomy and I respect those of
you who see your job as to balance human
life versus female
autonomy this resolution gives only one
side it takes the extreme position and
teaches that human life has no inherent
value for the first 24
weeks and the calls for autonomy in this
bill assume that it's only the woman
who's making the decision about the
abortion it's very naive to think that
abortions all happen without coercion
one Salient example was with this the
Scandal at this s new center one of the
counselors impregnated one of the girls
who is there and then took the child for
an abortion to cover that up we don't
know how many groomers or people
prostituting young people are using this
to cover up it's not just a young
woman's
Choice I'm also wondering if there's any
pro-life medical professionals that
avoid areas where they might feel
compelled to perform abortions and
that's something that we I I haven't
heard anyone look at or
study when someone says something is
science shows or is not in dispute then
it's a pretty good idea to check on that
and dispute it right away to make sure
it's right there to what degree there's
a correlation between um abortion
restrictions and increased abortions and
just looking quickly here they're
counting um things incidents that really
have nothing to do with with abortion
laws and there's also a concern that
these abortion um pills the medications
that people are taking they didn't go
through any serious clinical trials and
how how dangerous are they no one's
keeping track of how many are are
affected there this is a statement that
I really don't want New Hampshire to
make let's let's at least acknowledge
that many of us feel that life begins at
conception like science does tell us and
deserves to be acknowledged thank
you thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak as Courtney
Reid from ACLU New Hampshire
hi good afternoon chair McDonald and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Courtney Reid I serve as
policy Advocate with the ACLU of New
Hampshire and I am speaking on behalf of
the organization in support of HCR 7 uh
to keep things brief HCR 7 would send a
strong message that in the Live Free or
Die State there's no room for attacks
against bodily autonomy and the right to
make private healthcare decisions HCR 7
also sends message that the legislature
understands the importance of the
physician patient relationship and as
expressly stated in the resolution that
an abortion is a critical component of
reproductive health care and to level
set abortion is a human right and this
right has been recognized by numerous
medical associations and as we've heard
from previous hearings and other
speakers that in the wake of bans and
restrictions that have happened after
dos across the country now is time to
take a stand to protect this right again
New Hampshire is the only state in New
England that does not have an
affirmative protection for abortion in
its laws and uh just some data after
that Fallout as to why it's so important
for the legislature to take action now
uh in 2022
after row was overturned at least 25
million women lost access to an abortion
in their home state HCR 7 offers an
excellent opportunity for lawmakers to
affirm their commitment to protecting
reproductive freedom and oppose further
restrictions and barriers to abortion
amidst these
attacks uh going further we know that
research finds that when uh access to an
abortion is restricted uh we see higher
rates of maternal mortality uh increased
poverty people are more likely to stay
in abusive
relationships and there's a widening of
socioeconomic
inequalities we've also seen in polling
at the national level and in New
Hampshire that a majority of Voters
support access to safe and legal
abortion so it's time for the legislator
legislature to recognize that by voting
in support of this bill uh I'm happy to
take any questions but uh I want to
respect the time of the committee thank
you so much thank you representative
Mark Helen thank you for taking my
question I notice in um the bill that uh
you're asking the house Clerk and Senate
clerk to each transmit a copy of this
resolution to the president of the
United States the United States Senate
Majority Leader and the Speaker of the
House of Representatives the governor of
New Hampshire the Attorney General of
new New Hampshire and each of the
members of the Congressional Delegation
um can you tell us what do you think the
anticipated responses would be what let
me rephrase that what do you anticipate
the responses
from the federal aspects of this
resolution to
be if I'm I'm sorry no go ahead thank
you so much for your question
representative sure I Ely I think I
would defer to the sponsors of the bill
to more appropriately answer that
question uh but to just ground in this I
just want to express that this is a
policy statement and I think that the
policy statement that uh we want to
affirm that abortion is a critical
component of healthcare that in the
granite state we don't want to see any
more attacks or restrictions on this
bill uh is something that is meant to be
transmitted
broadly thank you representative palazov
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so uh this bill is written
refers to specific policy by President
Trump so so I wonder do you know if New
Hampshire has any other law that uh
specifically uh lists uh president Trump
policy position in a positive FL or
otherwise thank you for your question
representative uh I haven't seen
anything in statute but uh I am familiar
with a few resolutions and other
proposed bills that have cited the
current uh in evolving landscape at the
national level which I think is part of
the reason why this resolution feels so
important right now as there's just so
much uncertainty about the stability of
care in the granite
state other questions representative
delus
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question just because you are the
representative of the ACLU I my question
might be a little offc Center does the
ACLU believe that abortion should or
could be used as birth control and do
you consider that
healthare thank you for your question
representative I ultimately I think that
that question is not rooted in the facts
of what reproductive Healthcare looks
like and I would defer to someone from
the Healthcare Community to give you a
better answer than someone representing
the legal
Community other
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Kathy
Stratton from the New Hampshire Medical
Society
good
afternoon
um Mr chairman members of the committee
my name is Kathy Stratton I'm the CEO of
the New Hampshire Medical Society and
I'm speaking today on behalf of the
medical society in support of this
resolution recognizing abortion as a
critical um comprehensive reproductive
Healthcare the New Hampshire Medical
Society is a nonprofit nonpartisan
Society of Physicians and other healthc
care clinicians the organization's
mission is to advocate for the
well-being and betterment of Public
Health in New Hampshire the society
envisions a state in which personal and
public health are high priorities and
all people who live and work here have
access to high
quality um Healthcare as You' heard from
the Physicians who have presented the
clinicians and the parents providing
testimony today elective abortion is a
safe
procedure and medical care and a
lifesaving medical process that takes
into consideration the physical and
mental health of a patient the
Physicians on my board of
directors the council that governs the
advocacy of the New Hampshire Medical
Society and the countless years of
experienced practice Physicians
practicing medicine and taking care of
New Hampshire citizens and Families
support this bill the medical society
strongly supports legislation that
recognizes the clinical relationship
between Physicians and their patient
within a non within a well-informed
critical setting the law codifies a
patient's right to bodily autonomy and
the right to receive safe and effective
Medical Care in conclusion the medical
society encourages the committee to
support HCR 7 and ensure that
individuals seek
Health Care in New Hampshire have access
to a full spectrum of reproductive and
life-saving Care thank you for your time
and consideration of Our Testimony thank
you representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so our existing
abortion law was passed in
2021 one year before the do's decision
came down so if row was suddenly to be
reinstated nothing happens with respect
to our law because our law is completely
compliant with row um and so what I'm
trying to understand and and I I think
is
just with you with the medical society
um if this law was to
pass what would you what would you do
with it h how would you take action on
it um how how would it benefit you
because we have a law that is fully
compliant with row I I'm just trying to
understand tangibly what you will do if
this were to
become uh to pass thank
you it's my understanding this is a
resolution um and that it's an important
form of
communication um that says to patients
what they have available to them for
care and um that says to Physicians that
that they have the support of the state
to provide this Medical Care
followup so if this was to pass would
would it would it go into official
Communications that you send out to your
your membership that you share with your
patients or is it and I'm trying to
understand how it's going to be tangibly
used it's one thing to say nous it's
people deal with the law They Don't
Really deal deal with resolutions so I'm
just trying to you know because it's a
very divisive issue and we're coming in
and and you know we're taking a stand
when we when we went with the fetal life
Protection Law it was a compromise
understanding that there's this huge
diversity of opinion with this issue and
so we're we're going in and we're
muddying things up a little bit and I
just kind of want to understand tangibly
before I go in and and kind of stir
things up how is it going to be used how
is it going to benefit how are you going
to put it out there and I'm still kind
of struggling to see what is the
tangible effect going to be thank
you I can't speak to other groups I can
speak to you know the association I
think that this is again a support for
the physician patient relationship um
for the autonomy of a woman um for her
reproductive health
and um you know I again I can't speak to
how the Ripple effects that this will
have moving forward I can only speak to
the importance of supporting
that thank you thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Maria
Wilkinson
thank you chairperson and committee
members my name is Maria Wilkinson I was
born and raised in conquered New
Hampshire um and as a granite stator I
know how granular we like to get about
New Hampshire um law and how focused we
like to get into what it means to be
living in New Hampshire but I come with
a masters in international human rights
law and I specialize in the
international Covenant on civil and
political rights and I support article
six the right to life um and at this
moment I would like to also say that I
support HRC 7 and uh the reason I say
that is because with a deep
understanding of what international law
says about the right to life um it's
about um the United Nations human rights
committee has never recognized that
abortion is included into this right to
life it is under um it would be more
well recognizing of the women attached
to that pregnancy than anything and um I
just really want to drive home that
sometimes we get so singular in our
focus and um sometimes the comments we
get to opposition of something that's
going to um enrich our human rights in
the state uh we forget that there is be
Beyond us there is greater opinion um
and there's I would like to also mention
why do we care about the international
Covenant on civil and political rights
in New Hampshire that's because the
United States has ratified that and
therefore um it's our duty under New
Hampshire to also recognize what the
Covenant says so I don't believe you'll
have any questions for me but if you
want to ask me a question about
international law I will be willing to
answer specifically about the right to
life any
questions okay I'm seeing none thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on HC R7 does anyone else wish to
testify if not I am going to close the
public hearing on HCR 7 those are the
only bills that we had uh to schedule
for public hearing today so I'm going to
close the this portion of our meeting we
do have uh we will be going into
executive session in uh perhaps I don't
know 10 15 minute recess would be
appropriate I know at least one party
needs to caucus so we're going to be in
recess uh for approximately 15 minutes
we
spe
just the therapy
a
new
e
e e
okay I'd like to call the executive uh
session into order our first bill to be
considered today is House Bill 73 um and
interestingly enough um we are missing
someone
so before I get before we get carried
away stepped out the clerk yes can't do
much without the
clerk while we're waiting yes I had
something from uh Mr Williams about the
health and services oversight committee
that was the ALS thing well no the the
thing is that I thought we were meeting
on the fourth Friday and we are the
because we're not because we're not in
session that was it school vacation I
will have to change a lunch engagement
then either that or you're going to have
to clerk oh please please change your
lunch engagement I just need to get an
update from all of us uh that lisal
issue reminds me okay I carefully wrote
in the
minutes because he raised that with the
department or with John Williams at our
last meeting and they you know remember
it thank you okay hold on now we lost
Jim yeah sorry you and Jim you and Jim
have a problem here you don't want to be
in the room at the same time getting
conflicting messages from no we didn't
have enough motion sheets that was okay
Karen's bringing
more and Jim keeps getting I just want
to make sure there's no conflicts going
on
here thank you Karen
anybody got a pin I want to see if I can
really hear it drop it's so quiet in
here so we're waiting on 6:34 we're
waiting on we well no we're not starting
with 6:34 but just waiting for everybody
to be in the room before we proceed
Jim's been waiting on an amendment that
will us possibly just
that is the most focused look I've seen
in anybody in a long time
way she's like just move
quick uh
yeah no I'm Expediting it we can we can
push that to the end yeah we will okay
all right again let's let's proceed uh
the executive session is is open
um first B to be considered as HB 73 and
representative Drew you headed a motion
I
believe yes I uh moved to OTP HB 73 okay
and I'll second that do you wish to
speak to your motion briefly uh HP 73 is
some language changes to the statutes uh
that in my opinion are frankly long
overdue regarding uh reducing harm and
um
treating activities that the state
pursues and with regards to substance
misuse uh the way that it should be
treated and that's pretty much it okay
thank you any other discussion oh yes
representative Weber
um as a result of the discussion at the
hearing I did actually have
prepared um an
amendment that would simply amend the
bill by replacing Section 8 with the
following this act shall take place
effect 30 days after passage because the
effective date was pushed way out in the
original Bill and so it was discussed at
the time that the bill came up that uh
perhaps having it take effect 30 days
after Passage would allow for the
benefits to go into effect considerably
sooner because I think it was pushed out
till maybe 2026 or something July 1st
2026 yes right so um I I absolutely
agree that this is a necessary measure
and I would hope that the mment would be
seen as a friendly Amendment and if if
it would be I will pass it out and offer
it sure or somebody else can offer it is
there any objection to this
U Mr clerk good
afternoon that's the only change right
that's the only change it's very let me
just take one more for
me it's very
short it just says this effect shall
take 30 amend the bill by replacing
Section 8 which is the enacting Clause
with the following this act shall take
effect 30 days after
passage okay in terms of a friendly
Amendment um do we don't have to have a
formal vote do we or do we we H it's an
amendment we have to vote on it yes but
I would offer it or I would defer to the
cler prer previous two motions removed
right um yes uh yes I think so
representative D will pull your motion
on on the this yes I will withdraw my
motion I withdraw my second uh
representative Weber you would like
would you like to move this OTP I I
would like to move Amendment HB to
Amendment HB 73 the number of the
amendment I am moving is
2025 021
9h and it simply makes the effective
date
considerably probably a year sooner than
it would be if if the bill remained in
its original form and uh with or without
this I will be supporting the bill but I
just thought it would give better effect
to the the intent of the bill okay I'll
second your motion okay thank you and um
any other discussion on this on this
motion of
OTP uh yes representative
palazov
um so I have some concern about this
bill and um this amendment making it uh
even more uh faster especially in terms
of defining it as a reduction of
societal and individual harm so my
concerns
about studying how
this VI definition can affect uh a scope
and a cost of some
Services uh provided uh and otherwise so
I
I uh I will
probably vote with the rest of committee
on the bill but uh I think uh um pushing
it even faster is not prudent so I will
vote
against okay any other
discussion yes represent of dep partner
uh as as someone who worked uh with
representative uh Bill Liber on the
initial uh creation of the governor's
alcohol and drug uh commission um had we
known in 99 of uh what harm reduction
was we certainly would have uh
Incorporated it into the uh the initial
legislation to create the commission um
uh I would uh we would have saved
countless lives countless dollars in uh
Healthcare costs uh harm reduction is
proven uh uh concept to help engage
people in treatment although that's not
its primary target its Target is really
to reduce health care costs and uh uh
illness so I would uh uh certainly uh
support this Bill thank you any other
discussion saying none I'll ask the cl
to call the r motion is ought to pass on
amend Amendment 2025
d219
h r merer yes rep
mlan yes rep damus yes rep kofalt yes
rep poov
no clerk votes yes rep marel yes rep
McGrath yes rep kessing yes rep Weber
yes rep McKay yes rep Woods yes rep
Palmer yes rep taes yes rep lontine yes
rep hartnet yes rep Lucas yes and rep
McDonald
yes vote is 17 to1 motion passes thank
you representative Weber do you have
another motion I would defer to the
clerk on the on the oh under underlying
motion if if he chooses to accept my
difference okay you want to move out to
pass it's basically the same bill
sure okay and I'll second it
okay uh I'll move otpa on HP
73 okay and representative Weber seconds
any discussion of
otpa seeing on when the clerk is
ready motion is out of pass is amended
on House Bill 73 one
second and you're
ready rep maer yes rep mlan yes rep
damus yes rep kofalt yes rep poov yes
clerk votes yes rep Markel yes rep
McGrath yes rep kessing yes rep
Weber rep McKay yes rep Woods yes rep
Palmer yes rep Tes yes rep lontine yes
rep hartnet yes rep Lucas yes rep
McDonald yes vot is 18 to zero motion
passes okay very good um that can't be
consent right what can that
be that a it's not a it's not an FN okay
so any objection to
consent okay I'll go on the consent
calendar yeah Matt Matt representative D
you'll write the report on that yes um
next up is hb994 FN representative Drew
you would believe you have a motion on
that
also I do uh I move to O TP
hb994 and representative damus do you
have a second
yes uh do either of you wish to speak to
your
motion
yes
um I think it's unconscionable that the
state pays for a medical operation that
is cosmetic and medically unnecessary in
the vast majority of cases and also the
pair of botched operations when this
operation is done incorrectly uh so I do
not believe that we should do that and I
urge you to vote
OTP okay representative delus do you
have anything to add to that
or no any other discussion on the
motion representative
lontine um yes I I am going to vote
against this am um the opop pass motion
um after that testimony I certainly came
uh home thinking that a routine
circumcision of newborns is is probably
not a good
idea um but I do have a problem that
this bill is just Banning the procedure
first someone on public insurance and
not for
everybody and in general I I'm opposed
to that um I think it's probably a good
idea that we have bless and maybe there
are other ways um of going about trying
to reduce routine circumcision such as
maybe making
um parents wait a month so they've had
time to think about it and maybe gather
more
information now that they've been home
with their newborn baby and before
making that choice I think a lot of it
is that they have to make a decision
like that while they're in the
hospital um but it is the discrimination
against just one group of people
depending on their
insurance you know and I have to say
personally um my first husband was
Jewish and and I agreed that our son
would be circumcised in a a Brit Mala
that happened at the synagogue but I
came home from the testimony feeling a
little distressed and I called my son
and I I I told him about the hearing we
had and he said I'm fine Mom I don't
even think about it I think the
testimony was really skewed from one
perspective the vast majority of my
peers were circumcised I'm not saying
that that's um right or wrong but I
don't think it's um it warrants our
taking this action against uh just
people who have one type of health
insurance thank you any other
discussion seeing none okay all right
the motion is ought to pass on hb994 FN
and the Clark is
ready rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep
damus yes rep kofalt yes rep poov yes
clerk votes yes rep marel yes rep
McGrath
no rep kesslering yes rep Weber no rep
McKay no rep Woods yes rep Palmer no rep
tez
no rep l montine no rep hartnet no rep
Lucas no rep McDonald
yes vote is 10 to8 motion
passes okay I assume there'll be a
Minority Report on well has to oh I
yeah
mat is on the majority
report Jessica Minority
Report
okay next up is House Bill 223
representative paza I believe you have a
motion uh I move for to pass on House
Bill 223
representative Maser I second okay
representative POF do you wish to speak
to your motion uh yeah yeah yes uh uh I
move for to pass an act relative to
licens and requirements for Health Care
Facilities that operate within 15 miles
of a critical exess hospital so this
bill uh uh limits restrictions and uh
will provide uh New Hampshire residents
with more Access to Health Care
we had very compelling testimony about
uh importance of access to uh for
example ambulatory surgical
centers uh and um at the same time the
the bill remains some protection uh for
uh for establishing a new hospital
near uh uh near critical exess hospital
near existing critical exess hospital so
I think it's a right balance and I ask
you to support
it thank you representative Weber I will
just say that the the Old Law the
current law was a
compromise uh back when it was passed
and then we've had various attempts to
restrict it and the concern that I had
then and continue to have now is the
effect that
uh certain businesses may have on the
funding structure of the critical access
hospitals nothing currently prevents
anybody from simply giving notice and
having discussions with a critical
access hospital and saying the practice
that we would like to establish is going
to enhance your um is going to enhance
what's offered to the the local
population but I think that we ought to
continue to take that into consideration
so I will be voting no on the ought to
pass thank you representative mlan and
then representative
pmer thank you Mr chair um I think since
our current law passed in in
2016 um I think we've seen access go
down not up I think access continues to
go down Lakes Region Hospital
went bankrupt had to be absorbed by
conquered Hospital Franklin Hospital
conquered hospital um so we we heard
testimony that it is very difficult to
find a sustainable model for the rural
areas of the state um and I don't know
what the answer to that sustainability
is I mean I'm not so arrogant to think
that I do but I do feel um that the
existing law and this 15 Mile exclusion
Zone um puts up a barrier to people who
would innovate and maybe are able to go
to to find that solution and so I think
you know this is just this is just a
small thing um and you know during the
questioning you know representative
Weber asked a question where you know
and it really struck out to me she she
says listen I live in a rural area but
it's not in one of these overlapping
disc zones and I haven't seen any
development there and I think that
really says it all in that you would
think if this was going to come in and
be a tsunami of people taking advantage
of that they would have already gone
into representative Weber's area because
everything is there are so many
interlocking discs that that little
small spot would be a magnet you would
think for people to come in and develop
but it hasn't happened so I think you
know the boogeyman that this is going to
just throw open uh the health care
Market in the rural areas and it's going
to completely destabilize everything I
don't think it's going to happen I know
that you know there is some risk for
sure but I think what we need to do on
this committee is we need to have a
realistic assessment of what the risk is
and weigh that against what the benefit
is and I think realistically if we do
nothing the model is not sustainable so
I will be supporting this bill and thank
you Mr chair representative Palmer so I
have real concerns about this bill if
this bill were to allow Primary Care
Facilities to open within that range I'd
have no problem with it um the problem
is that's not what's going to happen
because um as we heard earlier um during
Dr Nagel's uh discussion of his bill um
it's it's very difficult to run a
primary care practice in New Hampshire
that's really what we need and I mean
we're also missing OB services but a
surgical center there's a great example
of what happens so about 30 years ago
the um surgeons and GI people at Valley
Regional had a disagreement with the CEO
who was
um less than good at his job and so they
took all of their same day outpatient
surgery across the street and open a
Surgery Center and they very nearly put
Valley Regional out of business
and the the the difference between that
and an independent Surgery Center open
was that they still did follow their
patients into the hospital so if they
had a complication in their surgic
Center they took care of it they didn't
just say go to the ER but there's
nothing stopping a a surgery center that
opens up on the other side of Claremont
from closing their door at five and just
having a answering machine that says you
know go to the hospital in which case
Val Regional is again
lost revenue and this the same day
surgery is the revenue that's a lot of
the time keeping these hospitals afloat
and this year they've just had a 2.8%
cut from Medicare on most services so
they're even less able to absorb it
so
I I I get your your idea which is is
good let's try to get more services
available to people but I think this as
the bill currently is what would happen
is that it would be cherry-picking it
would be people moving in and taking
providing services that are well
reimbursed leaving the hospitals in
trouble so I think the only thing I
would support here would be a further
study to look at that and figure out how
to make this work so that there's
actually an increase in the services
that we really need rather than
potentially putting critical access
hospitals at risk for survival because
there're all their margins I mean in New
Hampshire and Vermont in the last years
most of the critical accesses access
hospitals in most years have been
running at negative balance so if if the
OTP fails I would support a and be
willing to participate in a study to try
and figure out how to get past my
concerns other discussion representative
Weber I just wanted to make it a little
clearer as
a follow up to my question and uh the
earlier comment by representative mlan
that my point was really that
in the spaces that are more than 15
miles away from a critical a from a
hospital not necessarily a critical
access hospital but a hospital nobody
wants to build because if there is an
incident if something goes wrong if they
need a hospital emergency room surgical
Suite other things on an emergent
basis uh they need to be a lot closer
and they need to probably be closer than
15 miles depending on how hilly their
country is where they are so um I don't
think the fact that nobody has come to
Walpole to establish one of these things
is
really um determinative because I think
they need to be closer and I think that
anytime there's something that will
result in positive Synergy between the
new group and the exist EX in hospital
the existing hospital is going to say
please come it's only when they are
going to be drained of important Revenue
that they are going to say sorry not
happening so uh for that reason I'm
still opposed but I do applaud the
concern with making sure that everybody
has more access I just don't think this
is the way to do
it other discuss question representative
Woods thank you I just um adding on to
the the lonia example um they had
difficulties and they got bailed out um
can we imagine if there had been say U
Surgical Center decided to go in there I
mean conquered Hospital couldn't have
bailed them out so in that sense um not
having the protections
we would be without even the hospital
itself which would really put a dire sit
a dire problem in that whole whole uh
area so um just to bring that again that
issue of you know dominoes do
fall any other
discussion representative TZ I than you
um you know I appreciate that the
there's a concern about sustainability
rural access but it is definitely not
afforded by this bill um this bill uh
would provide an opportunity for cherry
picking and will most definitely
undermine the fiscal viability of the
critical AIS hospitals they're called
critical access hospitals because
they're critical and um the current law
allows the study as representative
Palmer proposed we do studying I mean
and no entity has been denied to date so
the current law suffices with um
affording what has been uh suggested
here
today thank you anyone
else all right seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the rooll motion is ought
to pass on House Bill
223 rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep damus
yes rep kofalt yes rep poof yes clerk
votes yes rep marel yes rep McGrath yes
rep kessing yes rep Weber no rep McKay
no rep Woods
no rep Palmer no rep tez no rep lontine
no rep hartnet no rep Lucas no rep
McDonald yes
vot is 10 to8 motion
passes representative TZ is doing the
minority right and that will be an i
okay
sure is representative palaz off
um Regular calendar yes regular calendar
yes oh
yes um okay uh next up is HB 524 f n
representative
merer yes thank you Mr chair I move
ought to pass on HB 524
dfn representative
Drew second you wish to speak to a
motion representative merer yes thank
you um the National Library of Medicine
did an examination of the up the
universal purchase programs as a driver
of vaccine
uptake um Among Us States um back in '95
through 2014 and they found that Up
Programs were ineffective in increasing
vaccination rates and we find that DHHS
should not be in the business of buying
and selling vaccines for commercially
insured children through this vaccine
Association it is best to remove
government from involvement in the
purchase of medical products when
Private Business does this quite well
and cost effectively for vaccines for
adults this bill won't increase parents
cost to parents through deductibles or
co-pays Federal Law requires that all
vaccines for children be provided at no
cost to the parent for the vaccines this
bill will not change that vaccines will
still be required to be quote unquote
free this bill won't bring back measles
this bill will have no impact on
vaccination choices or rates there will
still be tons of vaccines for everyone
who wants them this bill is an
anti-science it has nothing to do with
vaccine policy it's simply a a matter of
who's in the business of buying and
selling a private use medical product
the state or Private
Industry okay any other
discussion representative
lamon yes I I can't support the uh a to
pass on this
bill first of all none of the um many
pediatric clinics nor the insurers who
are using this system came in to say oh
it's a problem we need to fix it because
it's not a problem it's working really
well and it's even if it's true that the
insurance will be
covered you know I thought back to when
my own children were infants and I was a
um a graduate student with very little
income and we went in to get our shots I
remember wondering if I had enough money
to pay for all the shots that day and I
was assured no it's all taken care of
you take away the vaccine Association we
go back to just oh the insurance
companies will still pay for it but then
you have the parents going into the
clinic wondering if that bill is going
to be paid the doctor's office then has
to negotiate with the insurance company
to make sure that's gets paid for them
you're adding this level of
complexity that will end up disrupting
the distribution of vaccines simply by
making it more complicated we have a
system that works very well and I think
we should keep it and not really decide
on a whim that we should do away with a
system that works very
well thank you representative
Weber I agree with everything that
representative ltin said and the only
thing I want to add is that yes the
vaccines will still be available to
parents at no cost which is great
but the reason the whole purpose of the
vaccine Association was to aggregate
purchasing power to bring down the cost
of procurement for
everybody and that means both people
covered by the state and people covered
by private insurance and so it and
people not covered by anybody so I think
that to repeal A system that is working
that has been established voluntarily
that nobody in the system is complaining
about um and which saves the state the
insurance companies and ultimately the
people paying the premiums for the
insurance money is really
shortsighted representative Woods yeah
thank you um secondary arily and my
opinion is that we'll see decreased
vaccinations uh a lot of the
vaccinations are carried out by private
practice they will find it economically
unacceptable and decide not to do
vaccinations at which point those who
want vaccines will now have to find
another
provider uh and that puts another layer
on getting the uh individuals vaccinated
uh so vaccination rates go down
um and um all the accompanying problems
with with non vaccinations and I think
it's a serious health problem thank you
representative delus did you have you
your a hand out or no I did not okay
sorry representative
McGrath I think that the free market is
really great at finding Solutions in the
pharmacy
um they rolled out
the vaccines when covid hit the market
flawlessly and the companies are
definitely going to make sure that their
products get into the correct hands and
secondly the vaccine rates are already
plummeted I believe because
of the
um I'll say the the lies
that uh been coming out from government
agencies people used to be lined
up for their vaccines and nobody is
coming in for their vaccines nobody
wants them so if we have the state
buying tons of
vaccines and running this program I
don't know what they're going to do with
them all because I could tell you
from from Retail Pharmacy there nobody's
coming in for vaccines anymore
representative
kofel thank you Mr chairman so I think
in as far as access is concerned I think
um you know we we see
advertisements all the time from CVS and
Walgreens and others of you know come
get your vaccine it's it's free or very
low cost um you know CVS in particular
is you know very closely affiliated with
one of the pharmacy benefits management
associations I think they have the
market power to buy and bulk and uh
that's an example of how the free market
I think can address this issue uh
without government intervention so I
will be supporting the bill
representative
lontine I'm sorry but I can't help and
look you know not looking at this bill
as an anti-vaccination Bill we have a
system that works very well and it seems
like the motivation of this bill is to
disrupt that system and I happen to
believe that vaccines work very
well my husband's father was po
paralyzed from the neck down from polio
in
1955 it will be a horrible thing if
children start losing access to the
polio vaccine because we Destro we
decided to disrupt a system that's
working very well to distribute that
my husband I'm sure he would have rather
played B baseball with his father in the
backyard than spend his entire youth
changing his father's bed
pan so think about what you're
doing this is not a problem that needs
to be
fixed representative Paz off and then
representative Parmer thank you Mr chair
so we had to numbers uh so
% discount and less than 1%
administrative fee but we have no no way
of confirming that it's actually
effective or U because like to expand
what uh representative kofel said like
we often know if you
are without insurance sometimes you have
huge cash discount and insurance
companies get disc discounts from um
service providers and uh drug companies
so definitely there could be discounts
even better than 30% uh we don't know
and the same with administrative cost so
we heard that the majority of actual
administrative cost lies outside it goes
for
example to DHHS and and uh mostly
covered by federal funds my run out uh
so the remaining cost that was shown to
us is the cost of having a simple
spreadsheet how much Insurance provide
the Spate and how much money went out so
paying hundreds of thousands for keeping
a spreadsheet uh seems excessive thank
you representative
pmer um so
I
guess I'm a little frustrated on the one
hand
um vaccines have saved more lives than
any other medical intervention ever and
they continue to do so in most of the
world where they're been used and in
this country we've vilified them for
some legitimate reasons that you know
people
um I
guess they're not perfect so the first
patient I saw when I moved to Clara the
F my the very first patient was a woman
who had gon Beret after getting a flu
flu shot on the other hand we don't have
1918 versions of the the flu we did have
covid that vaccine is effective
countries that adopted it better than we
do did ultimately better than we did
with with covid um
so anything that we do that
that further denigrates the the value of
vaccines um that is not legitimate
should they be studied better should we
have better vaccines sure absolutely but
I think we've got to be very careful
that we don't push this to the point
where it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
that we make it a little harder to get F
so the rates go down and we see say C's
nobody wants these well I I I don't
really
agree with that I I work in Vermont
where they have a similar program and
there it's crucial for the people who
don't have insurance because that's
that's how they get them then they don't
otherwise it would be a you know it
would be up to the hospital or the
doctor's office to provide them the
final thing two things I'll say is um
the where I go for my health care there
are some vaccines that aren't covered
um um it that Prov providers don't get
Co coverage for the vaccine so they
don't offer them because they'd have to
pay out of pocket to get the vaccine and
then they could all they could collect
from me is the administration fee and so
I have to go to the pharmacy to get
those vaccines like the shingles
vaccine and so I did because I had
shingles when I was 19 I don't want to
have it again I have the time the
motivation and the money to go do that
um but a lot of people don't have that
so anything that makes it more difficult
is going to be a problem and and
ultimately end up a public health issue
and um so my daughter uh had a baby last
July and basically um is thinking of
moving to New Hampshire she's that child
has had every vaccine to prevent illness
and what is my daughter going to think
if she's looks at you know going to
school in New Hampshire and 70% of the
kids are vaccinated not the rest um I I
just think we got to be really careful
about what we do with
this any final
comments seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the r motion is ought to pass on
HB 524
FN rep Maser yes rep mlan yes rep delus
yes rep kofalt yes rep poov yes clerk
votes yes R marel yes rep McGrath yes
rep kessering yes rep Weber no rep McCay
no rep Woods no rep Palmer no rep taes
no rep l montine no rep hartnet no rep
Lucas no rep McDonald yes V is 10 to8
motion
passes I assume there'll be a minority
report going to be a busy
lady okay next up is uh HB
634 representative kofo you have an
amendment I believe uh yes I move ought
to pass on House Bill 634 and I would
like to offer Amendment
H I already have a
copy some some may not though uh
amendment number is 0344
H yes representative palazov I would
like to Second representative palazov
seconds the motion of a to pass on the
amendment uh do either of you wish to
speak to your well after
the sure
sorry I wasn't sure who had one and who
didn't
everyone let me know when you're ready
um I representative kall W go ahead
thank you so as I believe I said in our
last exec session um I had reached out
to uh a number of people I know who have
family members with autism uh they
were uh uniformly of the opinion that
the autism Council um has not been
effective it has not met uh in several
years and that the work that they are
supposed to be doing is duplicative of
work that is already being done by the
um Quality Council uh on developmental
disabilities so the amendment uh
proposes simply to repeal the Council on
autism as it is
duplicative any discussion on the
amendment yes representative
Weber I'm going to be voting against the
amendment because uh as we heard there
are definitely concerns with the autism
Council as it is currently structured
but the bill was specifically entered to
address those concerns and do the needed
work over the next couple of years the
concern that I have is that if you
depend on the um uh developmental
disability Council
to uh
represent folks with
autism many of the folks with autism do
not count do not qualify under the
definition of disability so they will be
without
representation and I think that we owe
them the courtesy
of this opportunity to hear their voices
in both
forums thank you other
discussion I would just say that um I
had received an as did representative
kof while a number of calls
unsolicited uh some from my own uh town
about the council very frustrated on how
ineffective it has been hasn't met since
2019 uh urging that it be repealed um so
the to the extent that there needs to be
a forum um to to address autism this
isn't doing it and I'm not confident
that it will um so anyway and again this
is based on people who have been
actually dealing with it and actually
have autistic children so any other
comments not I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the amendment I've ought to
pass on Amendment
0344 R Maser yes rep mlan yes rep damus
yes rep kofalt yes rep poov yes clerk
votes yes rep marel yes rep McGrath yes
rep ring yes rep Weber no rep McKay no
rep Woods no rep
Palmer he left I believe he left yes he
did okay okay rep tez no rep lontine no
rep hartnet
no rep Lucas no R McDonald yes vot is 10
to 7 motion passes
okay uh representative cofal do you have
another
motion I move a to pass with Amendment
on House Bill
634 and second off seconds again uh any
further discussion representative kofalt
or any other discussion from members of
the
committee okay give the clerk a chance
to catch up yes catch up and then call
when call the rooll when
ready rep
merer yes rep mlan yes rep damus yes rep
kofalt yes rep palazov yes rep uh clerk
votes yes rep marel yes rep McGrath yes
rep King yes rep Weber no rep McKay no
rep Woods
no rep TZ No rep lontine no rep hartnet
no rep Lucas no rep McDonald yes vote is
10 to7 motion
passes chman I will write a Minority
Report with a recommendation about pass
okay thank you
okay next up is uh HB 704
FNA and representative Mark uh excuse me
representative lamus I believe you have
an motion on
that oh okay representative Weber
seconds representative delus would you
like to speak to your
motion I mean which one did I call the
right one I'm
sorry representative delus I'm
sorry iov this
because
personal experience with this and it's I
think very important to support people
who take care of their loved
onesy that I cried
when the
like subsidizing things and don't like
growing government and spending money I
believe this is
very that people are so to keep their
home save
money keeping their at
home any littleit help them so I think
that this is actually something that we
should
be representative Weber would you like
to speak also and I would just like to
Second everything that representative
Delma said uh from a caregiver point of
view and the testimony that we heard
was uh truly truly
moving uh the other thing and I had an
email and I was unable to find it just
now but um
State expenditures for assistance for
families keeping somebody at home run
somewhere around
$25,000 a year if that individual has to
go to a nursing
home uh it's more like
$75,000 a year or more because the
Specialized Care that um many patients
need particular L if they are dementia
patients is more expensive rather than
less expensive and as we all know the
patients who are the most difficult and
the most medically needy come to our
County nursing homes and um that is of
course uh a charge on our local
taxpayers so I for all of the
compassionate reasons and for um dollars
and cents Reasons I'm very much in favor
of this
bill other discussion representative
Palazo thank you Mr chair uh I cannot
support the bill with numbers as it
written but uh I must say that uh I I
agree that uh
it's a awful uh situation and difficult
situations when people uh have to care
for loved ones 24 seven uh challenging
for them I I also do not dispute that uh
Home Care is more effective uh than uh
ning uh homes but uh this bill uh it's
uh expanding government it's in complete
system with cherry picking it's
encroachment into uh private sector and
uh pushing out private charity and uh
one more reason
is resources that we
spent on U addressing symptoms we are
not spending on addressing the ca of
uh uh chronic disease epidemic here and
like uh I can I don't know if you want
examples but uh uh in previous uh
session this committee did not
support uh studying uh FL fluoridation
of water but later Biden's HHS confirmed
that
fluide uh can can be neurotoxic so uh
when we have uh uh some factors that we
can address that can cause early diens
and other things I think our focus
should be also on those things so
uh uh I'm uh I feel for the people but I
think that numbers in this bill uh just
don't match the
moment thank you any other
representative Kofa thank you Mr
chairman as a proponent of small
government limited government um I
understand uh concerns about spending uh
but as a proponent of small government I
would say this is exactly the kind of
program that I believe we should be
trying to support which is uh loved ones
family caregivers flexibility providing
that vitally needed support for people
in their home um at a time when they
really really truly need it so I will be
supporting this
one thank you anyone
else before I asked cler to call a rooll
I was proud to be a co-sponsor on this
bail I went through issues with my
mother U with memory issues dementia uh
she actually died 20 years ago next
month March 22nd so some dates you just
remember so so anyway I I understand all
sides of this but I was proud to be a
co-sponsor with representative walner on
this with that I'll ask the CLK to call
the roll rep Maser yes rep mlan yes rep
damus yes rep kofalt yes rep poov
no clerk votes yes rep marel yes rep
McGrath yes rep k
yes rep Weber yes rep McKay yes rep
Woods
yes rep TZ yes rep lontine yes rep
hartnet yes rep Lucas yes R McDonald
yes vote is 16 to one motion passes
any objection to
consent it's an oh yeah okay so can't go
on consent all right there no consent no
because it's a spend money it's second
committee bill um representative Del sh
doing the report yes okay thank
you okay next up is 743
FN and representative mlan who doing the
majority report representative
delus there is no Minority Report
on again 743 FN representative mlan did
you have a motion yeah I'm going to move
itl on HP 743 and I'll second
that would you like to speak to your
motion thank you Mr chair I'll be brief
the uh the the bill has two sections the
first section deals with the uninsured
um and I don't really think it does any
harm it builds on the federal no
surprises act and if that's all that the
bill contained I'd be okay with it but
there's a second component that deals uh
with the insured persons and and puts a
lot of mandates on the insurance
companies that the insurance department
was not comfortable with um and you know
we're we're a small Insurance market and
I don't want to do any anything that uh
would jeopardize coverage or actually
move prices up um you know I think that
portion of the bill should have went
over to Commerce where they are used to
dealing with these issues and have the
subject knowledge uh we heard testimony
from the insurance department that HB
705 basically is a bill that is covering
those components so um you know on
balance I would look for us to itl this
bill and um I'll be looking at uh HB 705
out of Commerce when it comes to the
floor thank you Mr chair okay thank you
uh any other discussion representative
palazov uh thank you mi Mr chair uh I
agree that uh it could be the case that
house bill uh
705 uh deals with insurance part uh
better than uh bill in front of us but I
think the part that address a struggle
of uninsured people is too important to
throw out this bill uh at this point so
uh uh I would still be voting or to pass
uh but I'm ready
to uh testified finance committee
telling them that uh we don't need the
insurance part of this bill uh but I
think it's still too valuable to throw
out thank you other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the cler
to call the all a motion is itl on HB
FN rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep
damus rep
kofalt rep poov
no clerk votes yes R Markel yes rep
McGrath yes rep Kess ring yes rep Weber
yes rep mck
yes rep
Woods rep Palmer still gone rep TZ yes
rep
lontine yes rep hartnet yes rep Lucas
yes rep McDonald yes so
but is 15 to1 motion
passes okay want to finance also so that
that cannot go to consent and
representative mlan you'll do the
report
sir okay uh we have one bill left that
we're hoping to exact today and that's
645 FN that there is an amendment that
representative kofalt has gone to
hopefully get from um committee Services
uh so if you don't mind just giving it a
few minutes um I know we're tired it's
been a long day but and it appears here
he is so it won't even be a few
minutes that consent calendar oh no it
can't because it's spense money it's got
to go to finance
H this is
645 this this 45 yeah we just did 634 oh
yeah well it was 10 to
7 for
representative calt I think everybody's
got a copy uh great I move a to pass on
House Bill 645 FN and offer Amendment
0558 and I'll second that do you wish to
speak to your motion uh yes thank you Mr
chairman so
uh the uh chair of the
um prescription drug affordability board
um former representative Gary Merchant
asked me to put in this amendment uh
because he beli that it clarified um and
improved the language in section e of
this bill otherwise the bill and the
overall intent of the bill has not
changed
um you know I think that the uh
well so that's that's me speaking to the
amendment um I guess I can speak to the
bill at large if we pass the amendment
sure any other discussion on the
amendment any
questions seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the rooll motion of is ought to
pass on Amendment 2025 D
055h rep Meer yes rep mlan yes rep damus
yes rep kofalt yes rep poov yes clerk
votes yes rep marel yes rep McGrath yes
rep kessing yes rep Weber yes rep McKay
yes rep Woods yes rep tez yes rep
lontine yes rep haret rep Lucas yes rep
McDonald yes vote is
is 17 to zero motion
passes okay representative kofalt do you
have another motion I do um I I move out
to pass with Amendment on House Bill 645
FN I'll second that and other discussion
put you um I'll just say that you know I
I think that some concerns have been
raised about the prescription drug
affordability board
um that it has not really been able to
fulfill its Mission I think that this
bill uh provides it with the tools that
it needs to fulfill that mission uh
which is greater transparency in
prescription drug pricing and um you
know with the ultimate goal of uh making
prescription drugs more affordable um so
I I support this bill U as a as a tool
for making that happen very good any
other question questions or
discussion representative Woods uh more
comment I think this is a step in the
right direction but I think uh underly
such a excuse me such other items as
pbms and their relationship to this
whole process which are under discussion
nationally and to some degree here and I
think hopefully this will allow us to
get some of that and expose the
pbms um and
solve some of this cost problem so I
think this is for that reason a good
step in the right direction good okay
any other disc representative
palazov thank you Mr chair uh I share
some concerns that there might be some
uh uh added cost uh of compliance with
this uh data sharing and uh and
that uh we are creating one more
commission that so far haven't done
anything but um I see it uh as giving
them a
chance and uh if in a few years we see
that there's no progress we can address
it uh then so uh I will join you in
voting for this
bill okay any other
discussion seeing done okay the motion
is ought to pass as amended on HB 645
FN and I'll ask the clerk to call the
all rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep damus
yes rep kofalt yes rep paulov yes clerk
votes yes rep marel yes rep McGrath yes
rep King yes rep Weber yes rep McKay yes
rep Woods yes rep taes yes rep lontine
yes rep
hartnet rep Lucas yes rep McDonald yes
vot is 17 to zero motion
passes and again this is an early bill
right so that will go on the regular
calendar okay that is all I had for the
executive session
today uh before we adjourn anyone have
anything else before we
leave again the house is not meeting
next week but um we are having hearings
next week which will be noticed in the
calendar we will not have an executive
session just hearings next week um so
with that unless anybody has anything I
will uh I'll declare us
ajour e